welcome in everybody to Saturday's
edition those are rounds nine and ten up
ahead here on the feet HS comm online
Nations Cup we're getting down to it
it's gonna be an exciting final day in
our regular segment of this event before
heading to the Super Final tomorrow on
Sunday and to help me bring it home this
Saturday with all the action is of
course the one and only the grand master
Robert has looking great looking great
today buddy and that suit and the people
want to hear from you and know what this
is all about what is this event and what
is the online Nations Cup
well the online Nations Cup if you have
not been following it is a great
tournament featuring six teams from
around the world four of those teams are
from countries one is from a continent
and the final team is from the rest of
the world comprised of some of the top
players who were not already seeded into
teams and you have $180,000 in prizes
for the first of online event of its
kind it's been a great battle and well
as everybody knows at this point team
China is already through team China has
already qualified their way they get
they guaranteed themself a spot in the
Super Final yesterday and of course we
will have a couple of other teams trying
to catch them Team USA and Team Europe
faced off early this morning that that
matchup is going to have all of our
attention and we're gonna be diving into
previewing each board and giving you a
look into what we expect to see there
but before we do let's remind everybody
quickly of the format of course we
already mentioned that all of this sort
of preliminary work we've been doing
which has been amazing it leads us to
who's gonna qualify for the Super Final
these six invited teams have been
battling it out throughout this double
round-robin and as we said two teams are
qualifying there wait till tomorrow
remember that in case of a tie the top
finishing team from the double
round-robin stage is declared the winner
I don't think we're gonna see that today
all China really needs is a half a point
in a match to pretty much secure that no
one can even tie them so will will most
likely be having a super final on Sunday
don't you worry about that the time
control is 25 minutes plus a ten-second
increment one of the most official time
coolers you can have in Rapid and as
we've said each team has four players
and of course team captains along with
them now Robert as we
talk about the standings again and we're
gonna start diving into previewing the
matchup here between Europe and USA the
first thing we wanted to do this morning
was remind everybody that we have a lot
of people playing for all these teams
and so we put together this graphic to
show how everyone is performing
respectively from each team now remember
that it's not exactly an apples to
apples comparison here Robert obviously
you young ye competing on board three
whereas you see a guy like a car
Nakamura competing on on board one but
still what it what speaks to you when
you look at who our top performers have
been throughout this event
well you yeah he's been amazing for Team
China
Fabiano Caruana of course for the USA
and you know these two players really
stood out to me our ten-year can make a
claim as well but it's really been about
you yang Jie and the Caruana in my eyes
well apone Aronian has had a great event
but I guess it's it's only slightly
tainted by a couple of losses on the
beginning and end on the bookends if you
will of his tournament he started off
with a tough game against our Tim Yvonne
day one and then lost to bring the event
to a close yesterday versus video
Gujarati so but otherwise yeah I mean I
think that those are kind of the people
we've been seeing be the top performers
you young he is uh well what can you
really say about the guy right he's only
he's only played one round less than
Hikaru Nakamura and he still has more
points right I mean that guy has just
been an absolute wrecking ball on board
three for China and if that continues
they are going to be tough to beat in
the super final but before we get there
let's start breaking down the pairings
Robert we start with team world versus
team Russia unfortunately for both of
these teams this doesn't have as much at
stake as they maybe had hoped for a
Saturday match but still gonna be some
of the world's best chess players
throwing down here for sure and you know
well for Team both of these teams
they're out of contention to qualify for
the super final we see that still
stellar lineups Weiser Artemio I
mentioned him by name earlier he's been
performing well and it's going to be a
great matchup featuring Alireza firoozeh
whenever you see for Russia in the mix
you know that your attention should be
on his game but unfortunately for the
team
the rest of the world they're not
competing for the Superfinal the other
team also not competing for the super
final is Team India but that doesn't
make their match coming up here with
China any less important let's talk a
little bit about that matchup here video
Gujarati onboard one is is the big
storyline right the team captain giving
himself a rest a rest round will it be a
rest day we don't know but vid it
playing on board one is gonna be
exciting for us to check out obviously
that puts pantalla Hari Krishna on board
too and Adi bond Bhaskar on onboard
three respectively so interesting stuff
here I mean I think I think you'd like
to see Team India continue to build on
their momentum of the last few rounds
going up against you young ji who's back
in the lineup maybe two to work out any
any kinks he might have developed
because he you know he missed around
yesterday you know tournament organizers
for bid and you see that four team
trying to Dingley rent sitting this one
out as team China has practically locked
up first place they feel like the load
management it can continue you Yankee
set yesterday here Dingley Ren will set
this round and maybe even delayed around
today just to make sure he's well rested
for Sunday super file and then we have
the the marquee matchup and there's
absolutely no debate about it Team USA
versus Team Europe this is a this is
this is where a lot of our focus will be
because it's it's really between these
two teams to qualify for tomorrow's
super final the the only real I guess
change in the lineup from what we saw
yesterday from Team Europe is a nice
Giri back in at board three young Krista
Duda played both rounds seven na
prospectively so your thought on Gary
Kasparov as the team captain's decision
to put Anisha in here he will be facing
Wesley so with the black pieces and
Junkers dubbed Udo went one out of two
yesterday where you young he just blew
him off the board with a blistering
attack and then JKD recovered against
Hari Krishna in a topsy-turvy game so
perhaps former world champion be great
Gary Kasparov was saying I even though
you scored that one point for us I'm
still not certain about your performance
and we need to win and we need to do it
now so I nice giri he has more
spirits in JKD does they're probably
about equivalent in rapid strength it
will change from day to day but I also
like the inclusion thereof Nana's egg
needs a Wesley so singled her out in his
interview yesterday yeah that is a tough
player they're on board for but I read a
crush has been equally formidable for
Team USA so this is a matchup that
clearly can go either way and it's for
all the marbles what do you what do you
give to Gary Kasparov looking at Wesley
so and Anna nice giri stylistically and
and making the decision that he thinks
that maybe because of young Christoph's
I guess slightly more aggressive style
at this point there is a little bit more
of an up and down in his play I was
thinking about the strategy there and
and and evaluating that even if he's
putting in a nice Giri you know without
any jokes meant about this to draw
Wesley so with the black pieces these
guys play each other so often at the
highest levels right and and I think
because of that maybe he just feels a
little more confident stylistically that
a nice Giri can can get the job done
because because Wesley so and him are
both very similar they play each other
so much and that prep might help him
hold the half point if that's what team
Europe needs I think you raise a good
point there Danny then if I need to win
and I read garry kasparov I'm probably
putting in JKD for it right
so the adventurous style and he can get
you a victory any given game but if you
are looking at this from that point of
view that you just said I just want you
to hold off Wesley so such a
strategically sound player who will
outlast you and grind you down in a long
game that a nice Giri with that
experience playing in the grand chester
every year you gets many games against
Wesley so and he's elite events that
this is a wise decision by Gary well
let's uh let's dive in here now we've
we've talked about what we think the
strategies might be but let's actually
look at the math here this is a kind of
a complicated graphic that we put
together this morning not and not in the
sense that it doesn't make sense but but
there's no there's a lot to take in
there so Robert obviously Team USA and
Team Europe as listed there are the only
two teams that can advance to join China
who was already qualified as you look at
the different possible scenarios there
and I'm not asking you to play
prediction or or play favorites but what
are you what are you looking at here is
as what seems to be the most likely
outcome of the different possible ways
that each team can
it's just for both the USA in Europe
it's winning you're in so if you wing
right as the USA against Europe it's
done it's right complete you have
qualified for the super final and so
Europe knows that and they can still
make it if they tie the USA and then win
their final match and USA smite China in
the final round so as you see here
they're different possibilities are
listed in front of you and for three of
the teams you're already out of
contention you're just playing for fun
for pride but for USA in Europe I mean
you control your own destiny what more
could you ask for but for a Europe being
down in that point and the overall
standings right now your task is a
little tougher
well and you know the one scenario
that's a little scary for the USA is
just to draw your attention to that
third bullet point that's listed under
Europe is that if they only draw Europe
then they're facing that really tough
matchup versus China right because if
they draw Europe I think we would agree
that Europe is going to be favored
against team world right and if that's
the case USA facing against China where
you were you gotta make sure you don't
lose that match that's that's or even
draw it right so if so if they draw
Europe and then draw China they do put
the Fate back in Europe's hands right
and that's what makes this really
exciting here on the last day I think it
does come down to you control your
destiny right here right now in round
nine that's exciting for all of us but
if there's a draw match here we are
gonna have some serious drama in this
last round we're Team USA has to get the
job done against China otherwise they
risk Europe leapfrogging them at the
last second it's very true and you know
nobody really knows what it takes to
defeat team China anyway but at least
you get the chance you get the
opportunity to play them on Super Final
Sunday so we'll see what is ahead for us
today well I'm gonna make make a call
here to bring up our daily question
based on your comment right there that
was a fantastic point nobody really
knows what it takes to beat China and
guess what our daily question is what's
it gonna take to beat China and the
super oh it's so obviously the
first step is getting there and that's
where all of our attention is going to
be today but use the hashtag nation's
cup and you know for those who are super
fans and you've been watching this event
throughout we also had you a key
had you with a question yesterday let
you play that the role of a team captain
so I'm actually curious let's get some
real answers what kind of lineup would
you would you feel for us a what kind of
lineup would you feel for Europe and why
from a matchup perspective maybe a great
answer well it will ultimately prove
kind of prophetic in terms of what we're
gonna see tomorrow in the Super Final
we'll see
either way we are moments away from the
first moves being made so Rob and I are
gonna take our last chance for a break
before round 9 gets going here don't go
anywhere
the fidei online Nations Cup continues
in just a minute
[Music]
and we are back here just seconds away
from the first moves being made we have
our our board ready our coffee by our
side some of the people in Chad saying
it looks like I just woke up they're not
wrong it was 4 a.m. here although I did
at least get dressed from the top up
okay you don't know what's going on down
low and and that's that's that's how
it's meant to be Robert you ready I'm
very ready I can't wait for this matchup
ahead of us between Team USA Team Europe
because I think that's where our focus
has to remain as they are deciding who
plays China tomorrow on Superfinal
Sunday and Danny when you see this game
here between a Caro and Maxine these are
players we've seen go head-to-head so
many times in elite super tournaments
over the board and speed chess
championship and the pro chess League
what do you make of a cards decision
just to play this kind of exchange slob
and a team ER approach uh interesting
going away from the theory we've seen
repeated a lot by Hikaru as white and
black he's been an expert in this the
the the closed structure we've seen in
the bishop before kind of Queens gambit
declined positions we saw him play it as
black and kind of get away with a
blunder yesterday against all arrays of
Arusha had us talking a lot in the
negara confirming in chat yeah it was
just a blunder which was pretty funny
but what do I make of it I mean I think
it's it's an interesting way to take
some of the potential theory risk out of
the position but also maybe us have mvl
guessing a little bit in terms of what
the footwork is Nakamura has plan
because in a position like this that's a
little more tame there's gonna be some
subtleties that decide who gets an edge
in the middle game and white gets to
dictate a little bit of that I guess in
terms of in terms of having the first
move but I don't really have any much to
draw to it but you are right we've seen
these guys play more on chess calm than
maybe any other matchup in history yes
and well I actually have some experience
from the white side of this line not
playing myself but as coach of the u.s.
women's team I've worked with this some
with some of the players and I won't
name anybody name I don't ruin their
preparation but the point is look at
this madam 85 it looks like you know I'm
the board not doing so much at some
point I would like to go into the c-4
square but the night on g1 has a much
more natural route Knight f3 Knight to
e5 so what and there is a lot of threes
play it and you see that with Bishop
before maxime can put pressure on this
pin Knight and pin it again with rook to
ca but the problem for black is after
that you can't pile up even more
pressure on and look what Maxime does a
knight aged 5 so I mean these Knights
and a five and eight drive he's trying
to find a very direct solution to some
other practical problems but this can
also backfire when you're bringing your
pieces away from the center like this
yeah I I don't have experience in this
position theoretically other than
highlighting that one of the things you
can know too is that even though blacks
bishop on d7 is objectively more passive
compared to the white counterpart
because the pawn structure creates
natural play on the Queen side you've
got these open lines and so if black
does get his dream kind of development
it involves rook c8 eventually the King
is out of the center of course but using
not just to see Foursquare but even
advancing the Queen side pawns and these
kind of plans are supported by where the
bishop is so sometimes you can evaluate
development of pieces not based on their
sort of optical activity right where a
piece just looks better in the center
but where is the piece most useful for
your plan where is the piece most useful
for your structure so that is one thing
I'll say about blacks position is that
sometimes these positions can seem
passive to start but black black's
pieces will suddenly seem to be right
where they need to be if play does get
going on the Queen side that's true and
the black King is sort of stuck in the
Senators for the time being because if
you can't castle with the h7 pawn now
under attack so white is actually lined
up pretty perfectly towards the King
side and as you look at blacks minor
pieces you have this 1985 bish one
before and it's offside night on h5 as
well so there's no coordination here for
black to feel so comfortable with you
know I would think about playing the
knight back to c6 in a moment pretty
soon no I'm sorry forgiving the dramatic
whoa this early but I just had to give a
whoa Thank You Keanu Reaves I don't know
it's just I want the light scores that's
all all right seven is hanging and h7 is
hanging
mamie okay so my immediately thought was
wait what no what no like what I don't
know I don't know I mean that wasn't
totally off the table but a cobra very
quickly came back to g3 so he obviously
knows something about the tricks here
and doesn't go in for this line but even
the computer wasn't just jumping to say
that it was very clear on Bishop takes
h7 yeah but it's something that you know
it's just like oh they raised a trusted
hit car yesterday and we shouldn't have
here Hikaru trusted nvo when he probably
should have because maxime playing
quickly and you're getting to this
position like Lee is not just blundering
a pawn and getting his King on the open
there is complications there because
your Bishop and Queen get tangled up
over there on the a trio in that
variation yeah for sure and one of the
best things about coming back is that
you rather than going in for these
variation trying to prove it this pawn
is unable to return safely right so
really you're all-in now with this sort
of commitment which while these pawns
together are gonna do some some good
control over the light squares if black
wants the e5 square is forever forever
his yeah and so I was just looking at as
well as some of the other games yeah I
was match up just buying the board to
battle I think we should head over there
Fabiano caruana and Levon Aronian have
moved along here
in a rural position
I mean look at these nights just
diagonal from each other and the night
on g5 & e6 are having a bit of a stare
down and white is just trying to free up
this Bishop on b3 because you know it's
not going to amount to any sort of
devastating attack nothing of the sort
but as these trades start to occur on
the black King side and eventual Queen
f3 bringing that Queen into the mix as
well then black King starts to feel a
little bit iffy and the Bishop on b7 not
really doing the same thing as a bishop
on b3 if that night on e6 were to be
moved out of the way so this is just
these little nuances here that white is
hoping for not to mention I was about to
say f4 and there's f4 is played by Levon
Aronian opening the F file trying to
increase the pressure particularly on
the f7 square
given lots of woes here and it's not
because the positions are that crazy I
guess I'm just a little bit impressed by
the aggressive nature that that both
these top boards are going with it feels
like we're gonna get some pretty sharp
games and Fabiano just wasting no time
right making no apologies for his belief
that he can get some pressure I mean you
highlighted the Queen coming every
Robert and I was trying to make some
exchanges to show like hey if this
happens this is Robert's idea but
advancing the f-pawn is the most
aggressive way to bring more pieces over
here and now now we're really going to
see something aggressive happen
we are and we're actually gonna see a
material imbalance as well because now
after Knight takes at four you take back
with the bishop and White has given up
this Bishop for the night but the one
good thing about what Y is doing here is
that wants c1 had not moved yet so
you're actually picking up some momentum
by developing your piece and getting rid
of it at the same time and look at that
f7 square that's going to be the target
for LaVon and I mean you know you take
back on that four with the rook black
plays h6 to kick this Knight out of g5 I
don't think you can allow it to stay
there for too long and there's just
long-term pressure down the F file and
on that f7 pawn in particular
yep Livan on the clock here deciding how
to recapture on it for I mean like you
said Bishop takes developing with with
the tempo makes sense but the fact that
he's pausing makes me wonder is there's
some other move here like now he's
already recaptured oh I'm not on the
live position oh there we go
yeah I don't think lavon's gonna pause
right there that would not be a good
sign if LaVon is thinking about
sacrificing in exchange for no good
reason there
been made I'm spying the board three
game here between Sol and Geary another
one that is moving very very far very
quickly let's head over there just to
make sure we've checked in on all the
boards in this USA versus your a battle
here in round nine
yep and so we see this position we know
exactly which opening it came from
because the two-on-one majority for
black on the queenside and the central
majority for white leads us to believe
that hey we're getting here from a Grune
felt and well we tend to like that
central pawn mass but white is a little
bit underdeveloped compared to black
you're Kingston the center and sometimes
that's ok your King comes you know up
forward instead of castling to the side
but in this particular position I mean
Knight to b4 of course is and he's just
gonna consider Knight to e5 to trade
knights and denim I don't know if I feel
like this is what the doctor ordered for
Team USA on the white side of this
position yeah but I I think you would
say it's probably also not is it really
a position that has a ton of risk to
lose maybe maybe I guess I mean it is
gonna be one of those unbalanced
Grunfeld endings where like you said the
long-term advantage of the two om1 will
it will it pay dividends but I guess I
always feel like with white already
having the C file in these end games
that usually they're able to dictate
some of the pace if the knight moves
black does black ever try for things
like e6000 and while it can't be
defended because if a capture has to
happen black has even putting putting
even more pressure over here on the
queenside interesting so 95 played
rather doesn't Danny I wasn't think in
terms of risk I was thinking in terms of
match strategy you know you got a nice
gear in there to be solid and just say
I'm gonna hold off Wesley so and I'm
just wondering you know if this
particular opening without the Queen's
on the board where Anish you know has
some experience but Wesley playing
quickly like does this give Europe more
chances just hold down this board and
then play four more with the white
pieces right okay yeah that's fair I
mean I guess we'd have to talk overall
match strategy from every board
perspective and and what result do you
expect to happen right respectively on
each board I mean if your team you would
say looking at this ahead of time where
were you looking to get your points I'm
asking generally I mean it's it's a
tough one to think about as I'm looking
through the board's looking for Irina
crushes game versus magnesia
[Music]
don't have it up right now
[Laughter]
there we go
yep and we have a more oxy bind
structure which I always like from the
white side and the reason why is we're
getting a little too more into a little
more chest in this particular game is
look at white spawns preventing any of
black pawn breaks right d5 is covered d5
is covered you know where's black move
her pawns in a position like this and I
just feel like you're always just
gasping for air trying to find a way to
create some active threats for yourself
yeah whereas white play is actually
quite straightforward you often just put
your queen on d2 but a rook on d1 and
then choose if you want to work on c1 or
rook on e one or even a rook on b1 like
there's some flexibility to whites
position that black really doesn't have
although Irina does have a lot of
experience in this and just because I
may be uncomfortable with a position of
this nature doesn't mean that she is
yeah you know the accelerated dragon
does take a lot of experience to get
it's not exactly a move order that was a
traditional accelerated dragon we came
via this but a Rasul mo where c4 being
played later now earlier in the event
holy faun played the move c4 right here
and what a very nice game against Irina
crush but not as agnesi goes for the the
mainline I guess still getting a mirach
see blind structure as you highlighted
Robert and I'm you know I've played
these positions on the black side of
course and you're always slightly worse
until you either lose or or you
eventually change the structure somehow
and okay b5 and d5 are very hard to
manufacture the other option is to make
a trade and then try to offer yet
another trade so that the dark squares
can just continue to be available to
black and if that becomes the case that
is the sort of the long-term asset of
blacks position is the wallet has much
less space and is definitely worse from
that perspective if the pieces are
traded what is space really right and
that wasn't meant to sound like
existential you know but what is space
if pieces were traded it can be holes in
open weaknesses so that's kind of you
know the reason black plays these
positions is not to you know not to get
usually some sort of advantage in the
middle game but to play for the long
game
and actually an example of that Danny is
if black plays 97 next which is
typically her plan in this position your
Bishop on g7 not doing so much and then
f6 or dominated and if you can trade on
Square D 4 and then trade Queens
eventually on the c5 score let's say
that's where you're talking about
there's some holes in White's position
because of all these pawn advances and
so maybe you can take advantage of that
but I think you summed it up extremely
well with white is sort of better until
at the end of the game right that is the
point of playing this opening from the
white side you know strategically are so
sound there no real weakness is to
exploit and you have so much more space
that you just control the shots now you
call the shots on what's happening in
this one yeah and it's a weird thing to
say that White's just better until the
end of the game and somehow black can
somehow hold those positions and in rare
cases win them if it's over pressed but
it it is definitely no argument that
white has a slight edge in these
positions so as we take a step back of
course we'll just remind everybody that
there are a lot of other games going on
in the other matchups of course we have
team world and team Russia a team Indian
team China we're gonna kind of continue
to focus on some of these top games
between the USA and Europe because it is
kind of where all the marbles are are
being held right now let's go back
quickly to the board one battle
hey Carlo versus Maxine Boston the Grove
not a ton of progress there hikaru still
on the clock deciding how to approach
this position what do you think the
critical decisions are I mean obviously
the e5 square is gonna be home to some
sort of white minor but other chances
white looks to be really aggressive here
and and even even keep the King in the
center at the idea of eventually
advancing things like g4 and some of
these structures that you would do like
in a Dutch or as a karo just just
thinking about you know making sure he
double checks a more straightforward
playing Castle short put a rook on the C
file fill the e5 square and go from
there well part of this decision is
based on which Knight he wants to allow
to capture his dark square bishop
because the 985 is threatening to do so
but it's not really a threat opening up
the H file with the rook on h1 is can be
good for white and if you go Bishop to
e5 you make the matter on h5 look a
little silly but then an a5 can come
back to c6 and attack that big
and now no matter what the trade for
that Bishop stills would leave white
with a slight advantage so I wouldn't be
concerned about that but that's actually
a pretty critical decision at this point
right and adding to that is what you
were saying are you just gonna castle
bring a rook to see one or you can play
pawn to b4 is that kind of expansion
what you want on the Queen side kicking
that night away for the time being and
then just claiming even more space
across the board so I think that's what
Hikaru is thinking about not just this
move but how he's going to continue the
strategy say six moves from now and
that's why this is a critical moment
yeah well he caught up taking a lot of
time here and not not something we talk
about every day right obviously he's one
of the fastest players in the world and
is used to pressing an edge on the clock
but I think he respects and appreciates
how critical this game is for his team
him him having the white pieces versus
MBL versus Fabiano having the black
pieces versus against LaVon right I
think that of course each one of these
games can be different we see players
get points from both both sides but I
think you know it's just how critical it
is that he's the one pressing against
Maxime today right because off it's not
about winning the game it's about just
putting pressure on the other white
boards and that is something that I
think a lot of people who don't have
experience in these team chess events
don't quite understand because typically
in a game of chess you are solely
focused on your own game nothing else
really matters maybe in the final round
when you're playing for first place and
you have to see how your competitors are
doing but just really it's about your
own game here you're looking at five I
own a car one is game I think we should
actually just take it's a great time to
look at that game because when I look at
that game Danny and looking the King on
h8 all of Wight's pieces trying to
battle it down on King Satan exactly
you're nervous
I mean I'm always nervous but go ahead
I'm nervous for blacks position here or
loving White's position depending how
you look at it so yes because you're
sitting here very passively your we
think about how can black do something
of his own Brennan just fending off
White's ideas you think it would move
like d5 but d5 has always meant about
pawn to e5 and I'm just kicking your
night away and opening up the board a
little more and I would think about
honestly moving my
away from f6 which sounds like robber
what are you talking about it's my only
really developed piece on the
third-ranked but the pressure down the F
file is about to continue to increase
and then your knight will not be able to
move because the f7 pawn is behind it
not to mention Knight takes h6
sacrifices to then take on f6 and just
break open and blasts open that King
well as passive as it looks I mean
Knight to g8 has to be considered
because it over protects Knight to e8
also protects g7 but it disconnects your
your pieces for future coordination
which I think will have its own tactical
dysfunction so Knight to g8 is and is
filling or opening the square if you
will on f6 for the bishop I mean that
makes sense as passive as it looks but
there's no way white isn't just better
here and this is this is one of those
positions Robert that I mean you and you
and I both are sort of it's obvious in
our tone we have a feeling that white
could get a really good attack here and
this could be a game where black gets
blown off the board right and we know
vivan is super dangerous and rapid and
has had a great tournament overall
despite a tough loss to end yesterday so
I think Fabiano pausing for good reason
here and don't let the computer
evaluation fool you here yes it's only a
teeny bit better for white objectively
but this is a position that could very
quickly just be just be crushing for
white and you know 19 siege 6 as we
mentioned already you know on the docket
for why just you have to consider it so
thought I know he's probably gonna burn
some serious time you're thinking do I
retreat this line to GA to h7 like is
there a difference between those squares
and of course there are differences just
somewhere the knight can move next if
it's going to move but you know you're
creating a defensive setup now yeah and
this is not an easy choice because you
can see many plans for white here and
blacks ideas are really how do I make
sure I don't lose this game rather than
hey where's my activity coming from you
know if you could play c5 c4 or
something like that super quickly for
black then maybe you have some chance to
actually claim I'm doing something of my
own
Radames pairing off threats but right
that's a long story with your king side
being so open over there now I think but
I think that's an interesting plan
certainly you would want to consider
that just because it's it's an
aggressive defensive idea right the
whole reason you're doing it is
not in a typical way where you think of
a queen side racing against a King side
attack but just purely to basically
strangle away one of whites potentially
dangerous pieces I want to quickly go
over and back to Irena crush's game with
none is like me Z because the variation
we predicted actually happened on the
board the knight retreated to d7 to to
offer some trades and obviously Irena
did not go full and game offering with
Queen to c5 she brought the knight back
to f6 but this is the kind of position
that if you're an accelerated dragon
player that you thought of when you when
you went for this right again
objectively and the computer you can see
likes white just by a little bit here
the space is there for a reason but
without a lot of pieces the space can
backfire and black structure if you just
look at it doesn't have a ton of
weaknesses yet ninety-five has an idea
to maybe make one the whole point for
white in this position is to make this
trade so that the e-file can give a a
long-term weakness here on the e7 pawn
but but you can understand why every to
play this right it I mean if she feels
confident defending it it is solid black
was never pretending to maybe be winning
in an endgame but I think she has a lot
of experience that could hold this well
speaking of experience none as like
needs a experience to know that 95 is
just a good move because as you point
out the e7 pond that's gonna become the
target and you sometimes you have more
space you're like I don't want to trade
pieces because the side with less space
is typically more cramped but here
you're creating a very concrete plan and
piling up pressure on this Pony seven
swinging of rook to e1 doubling on the
e-file and that's going to be some
difficult news for black to me and if
the Queen's stay on the board it may not
look like an attack is brewing but
sometimes you just fight h4 and try to
play h5 and if you can get it h6 and
some dark score issues for the black
King and that is a long story
black obviously has moves to meet that
idea but h4g for the white king is so
safe over here because black has no
that's like open lines to start going
after it so I'd rather think of black
like you said objectively black can
fight this one off but with this now
practical weakness in the e7 square it's
really not so simple yep
know it and it's a great point too that
you highlighted the
come combination of the e7 poem being
Wieck week also with the the alpha0 plan
over here as Robert Downey jr. said in
Tropic Thunder always go full alpha zero
and this is this is a dangerous plan for
black to be worried about Irina crush
gonna pause here to think about it I
guess we should head back to board three
real quick okay Wesley so in a nice Giri
a lot has changed here white completed
development but I don't know
instinctively I like the transition more
for black east six was played by a
nation again this is a typical idea in
the grünfeld when white has this
advanced structure because the tension
sort of favors black trading is almost
never good and that means the tension
favors you you can take what you want
Anish decides it's sooner rather than
later for him because of the nights kind
of troubles and opening up the center is
gonna maybe take advantage of the king
what what would have happened to your on
Bishop a5 I guess taking e4 yep and we
go back for the pin over here on the
e-file
exactly and kinky three would be the
only way to break the pin but then
Bishop b5 check happens sorry I'm king
d3
yeah but then Bishop b5 check and you're
walking right back into the pin because
you otherwise can't protect your bishop
so yep nice tactical little motif there
but Danny as we go to the live position
with Bishop h6 I understand Wesley's
plan you know he's trying to take over
the C file but the D pawn is you really
that's in it's one that you want to call
a passed pawn and you know an asset but
it's kind of a liability it's not that
easy to keep hold of and if you're lucky
a check now and then bring your second
rook over to d8 I mean you're gonna
quickly see that pawn getting some
trouble yeah and the King doesn't
exactly know where he wants to be
obviously coming more into the fray is
maybe maybe something you'll forever
regret and coming back word can only
cause dysfunction in terms of your
pieces here putting the bishop on e3 is
one way to deal with the check but you
sort of self pin you worry about ideas
where black can kind of continue to put
pressure there so I don't know I'm uh
I'm also liking anis Geary's opening
here
Wesley not getting his best possible
variation on the white side of a
grünfeld and he's got it he's got to
work his way out of this he does indeed
and I mean as I look across the four
boards Dania I just sort of like
Europe's chances on aggregate I don't
really see a USA advantage on any
particular board whereas on two of the
boards I really like your ups position
that's on boards two and four so with
the white pieces it feels like Levon
Aronian and Nonna's like needs they are
pressing and doing right just just what
the team needs and from boards one and
three I mean I haven't looked at board
one I mean I like to Cara's position
early so maybe it's so good but on this
game in particular doesn't feel like
Wesley's position is one where you feel
comfortable or confident used winning
chances and it really justifies Gary
putting in an Asian boy three to fend
them off right well and we talked about
that right before it started that
stylistically I think he just looked at
a nice giri I mean a niche hadn't had
his best event and he would be the first
to tell you that but it you know these
guys are the world to lead for a reason
and he knows what a niche is capable of
and here he's kind of proving
good solid prep is black and put himself
in a very good spot here for Team Europe
so what a huge result that would be for
a niche to kind of not necessarily
redeem himself but redeemed the event
because the event itself hasn't been his
best and and really find it here in
these on this last day this should be
three responded very quickly to rookie a
chat kind of the only move yep how do
you know how do you get the initiative
here before white gets a move like Rupp
to c7 that's and that's kind of the
whole idea of Bishop a6 and these
Grunfeld is to own the C file I'm
expecting Bishop a4 to not allow you to
play rook to d1 because and there it is
so I wanted to play rook to d8 but then
I thought maybe you play rook to d1 and
then you're protecting that D pawn in
advance so I'm thinking I want to play
both of these moves rip demon Bishop a4
but why not start with Bishop a4 you
can't kick my Bishop out because my
knight covers the c-4 square from your
rook and then I play rook to d8 next and
go after the d5 pawn yeah now when you
play rook d8 there there is still lines
with rook c7 and a trade that can happen
but it feels like if that's the kind of
direction the game goes black has to
have something because of the Kings
awkward spot right I mean I know I'm
being a little bit superficial but I'm
sort of assuming that that if the trade
happens that the white King gets in
trouble at some point it's not extremely
well placed I think we can say that at a
minimum because you take a 7 I take d5
I have Bishop h6 just as one example of
what I can do later as black and there
are other ideas as well but what's white
going to do you know rook c1 maybe but
it does feel like black is the one with
a sort of initiative here and not a
comfortable position for Wesley yeah and
I think Bishop h6 is maybe almost good
enough in some respects that trading
here and I saying the e pawn has to be
good there's also ideas of Bishop e5
check where the trade brings the rook
over to the the B file and maybe the b2
square so okay like these guys are going
to be calculating this much more
concretely than our sort of high-level
look at what might happen but but yeah
it feels like black is in a good shape
here for Team Europe so spying some of
the other games one of the games that is
most interesting to me I just want to
check on real quick
is uh Allah raised a ferocious game
versus Sergey Karjakin we're probably
not going to have as much time spent on
the top games of the other matches
everybody as you can understand Team
Europe and Team USA are fighting for
their super final lives but this one
looked a little fun so I thought we'd
we'd at least look at it quickly and
and give our thoughts about it a King on
g8 doesn't look great
hey that rhymed hashtag you're welcome I
appreciate it and the king of G doesn't
look great but I think what black is
trying to claim is that the pawn
structure is superior and you might say
well black spawns haven't done anything
you have this one little paunchy from f7
d5 but this one 'if i've in particular
is one that perhaps wandered a little
too far
so if black is able to say trade queens
at some point with a queen e4 queen g6
or something like that then maybe this
pawn on e5 sticks out a little bit and
I'm I think that why is to be perfectly
fine but somebody tells me that like
it's also totally fine for black and
yeah Queenie for it's over the king side
is probably the first idea that comes to
my mind
yeah that's an instructive instructive
point not just because getting the
Queen's off the board helps you when you
when you feel like your king might be a
weakness but like you said as soon as
the king is no longer the main issue on
the board you start looking at other
types of weaknesses and one of them has
to be the pawn here but okay if white if
white somehow avoids the Queen trade I
guess the goal is and LK this is
obviously it comes with a lot of risk
but if you start advancing on the King
side and you've got rook lifts that can
happen you know your hope is to bring
some pressure over here before black can
solve his problems but yeah the more I
look at it the more I think that that's
a bit of a pipe dream and that black is
moments away whether it be the Queen
comes over back to g6 some cases you can
even still play h6 and if the Queen is
not hitting f7 you can quickly castle by
hand so ya firoozeh daniels gives a
Queen h4 I keep talking McWeeny for
Queen ji-sun one move does matter like
Fabio six yesterday yep well Queen a4 to
h4 is not a move you play every day
so I guess we didn't spy it but you know
black offering the Queen straight
doesn't mean white has to take it I mean
you can see white back up and this was
sort of my point is that if this happens
okay then f4 then Bishop to d4 and then
rook f3 and over like these are the kind
of positions that you can also struggle
with as black I know it's a French where
you've gotten rid of your bad bishop but
it's still a French pawn structure right
I know you feel about that and that's a
good thing
the French pawn structure I like the
bishop I don't but I also
you know I mean this game not too much
happening just yet but Danny the LaVon
gaming it's Fabiani has changed a lot
Madam's let's head back indeed all right
we have to back up and see what the last
few moves where this matchup is of
course gonna get a ton of attention if
you're just tuning in again LaVon just
went all in here to open up the kingside
quickly we were talking about this
position just a few moments ago what is
black gonna do rather than we're
treating the night Robert Fabiano makes
d5 work and he plays d5 and that's a
move that I didn't like at first but I
do tend to trust Fabiano when he is you
know making moves he's the number two
player in the world for a reason and I
mean the way this game went from here
yeah he went five which was good and
expected and then he went d4 so and you
see I can see the evaluation bar drop I
don't have the engine lines but it
didn't like d4 so maybe d4 was a little
bit slow and a like a queen g3 type of
move or something like that just first
was a was probably what the engine is
asking for it but yeah I mean d4 I don't
know
it's clearly trying to stop c5 and maybe
place c3 Bishop c2 as you were saying
but it feels like Fabiano with Bishop g5
was buying his way out of this ya know
it's interesting point because d4 is a
move to move you want to play right it's
kind of a warm and cozy move it
solidifies your structure keeps the
bishop on b7 blocked and if you do get
c3 and the bishop relocates it's right
in a perfect world it's very pretty and
very comfy right but it's just a little
bit slow and like you said Queen to g3
for Aronian maybe then Bishop g5
the main point is that you're just a
little more direct in your attempt to
just continue to bring pressure over
here I guess something like this and
also at some point you've night takes g7
with h4 to follow I mean there's so many
ideas in such a position that Queen g3
can't be met by Bishop c5 then yeah this
is very scary right because if you play
the move like rook c8 I'm just assuming
yet the you know we must this just
doesn't seem good right you move you
removed your rook
and I mean honestly d4 does little a
good move and I said I saw the
evaluation bar get up so I was like okay
clearly this is where the moment was
during a game you don't have that
knowledge so you can't really fault them
on too much but if we go to where the
game is now if we keep going forward
here LaVon is sacrificed in exchange and
he trades Queens in a fancy way and now
there is an exchange for one pawn and
these type of positions typically you
say well I have a rook for just one
night and one pawn so that sounds like
good material but if we continue up to
the live position Danny like what is
black going to do that's the essential
question so you on paper you have an
advantage in terms of material but
practically speaking where is your
breakthrough going to come from Brooks
need open files to be useful and one of
these nights is probably going to c5 so
I think that you know this position is
still chances for both and that's in the
interesting nature of exchange
sacrifices is that you know a knight can
do things obviously that a row can't
and here the c5 square is one of those
places that tonight might want to jump
to and say your rook can't kick me out
it's it's annoying square for me to
latch into I agree totally right in the
exchange sacrifice school of chess from
the great Armenian world champion to
Grandpa Trojan lots of lots of great
exchange sacrifices and something that I
think is a dynamic part of the game but
I have to just say that that said I mean
if you're Fabiano and you're comparing
this this to the position you were
facing back here I mean I don't know I
mean sign me up
right oh this is yep three times over
because overwrite my position here this
position felt moments away and you and I
were calling for this this watch out
everybody this could be a blowout so if
you're if your car wanted I'm not saying
that
LaVon isn't holding some cards here
right I don't really agree with the full
engine evaluation that black is just
better I'm with you because of the extra
pawn again computers are biased toward
the the points the material white is in
control a lot of plans but like you said
the very nature of an exchange sac is
super double-edged black will get the
rook here and the bishop will be kind of
developed
c8 where it can protect against the
night on c5 it holds the diagonal and
black wants to slowly engineer an f6 if
f6 can come in and the position starts
opening up for the rooks to flex this is
this is uh this is a3 result position
right now yeah and I do believe that
black is clearly better here definitely
the one in charge of a position like
this but I think that we often just make
a mistake looking at the material and
thinking that automatically means that
someone is better here the material does
give Fabiana the advantage so something
went wrong LaVon lost the thread of that
critical moment d4 but it's not the
worst position I've ever seen that's for
sure yet when you're down in exchange
the question is is if Vaughn lost the
thread here did the opposite happen in
the board one battle between Nakamura
and Maxime boshy a the Groff let's head
back over there cuz it feels like here
well while we were liking the Vaughn's
chances to start his white we were kind
of liking a Carla's chances to start his
white but this game has moved very far
along the other direction Maxime has the
bishop pair and he's pressing on the
kingside something something happened
here let's let's back this thing up did
he this one went from positional to
attacking yeah and lavon's gave one from
attacking to positional so they had a
total mirror effect going on and yeah
take us through it it seems that the
computer didn't like that after a much
of a delay once you've castled here
you're no longer in a in a in a great
spot to mean Knight g3 because you
really loved the idea of your rook being
open and the computer really wanted
white to save the bishop I think to
maintain the balance so when the when
the trade happened here on g3 feels like
maybe that was maybe the start of LaVon
started out LaVon maxime switching gears
to start spying what he might be able to
do on the Kings side with the absence of
the light squared bishop I'm sorry the
the dark square bishop for white you
know you always see this kind of idea
happen against these double pawn
structure because you can fortify your
King side but it also can create a more
advanced pawn that's easy easier to
attack and what you mean by attack play
age five h4 and start breaking through
crashing through on them on the Kingston
if you go to this position here as we
keep going to the live board just
because some moves are being played I
mean III think that Maxime is just mean
how could you ask for better because
you've two bishops you're starting to
attack the White King on g1 you can open
up the H file at any moment and where's
White's play going to come from when
this you know C file is the only open
file for white but the bishops cover all
the important squares over there well
you just make a pound for pound
comparison one piece at a time
rook versus rook advantage black right
I mean Queen versus Queen even even
advantage black in terms of the
potential power the bishops are are
right now at least the dark square
Bishop is putting pressure where it's
needed I guess the long-term pros for
white is that if you defend off the
attack let's say that this trade as
scary as it looks if it doesn't yield
anything if this King can somehow sit
cozy on f2 when that Square opens up
white wants Knight d5 to slowly unwind
on the C file but but I'm with you and I
I think even Hakkar would agree I'm not
exactly sure what he would say in terms
of where the thread happened out of the
opening but obviously some some tricky
footwork as we like to say when
heavyweights battle and Maxime got the
better of it and I like King of seven
because I was going to say that King
might make a dart over for the Queen
side because for now black is trying to
crash through on the Kings side and so
either the King can go all the way over
to the Queen side as needed or at some
point you know get prepared for an
endgame your King more advanced in the
center can be good but I think Hakkar
gonna rely on some sort of fortress that
you were talking about with you know lg
g2 3f g3 put your King on f2 and say you
just can't break the position open
anymore because you can't play e5
without dropping the d5 pawn and if I
would be nice just continue pressing
forward opening lines and diagonals but
yeah I don't see that happening anytime
soon yeah it's interesting the last time
we saw her car in a tough spot was
actually with the white pieces against
uh Vishwanath on and on so this is this
is not even as bad as that was and
Hikaru a very resourceful and pesky
defender the thing you have to be
worried about though is not just all the
X's and O's we've highlighted but the
one practical factor we haven't given
attention to I think MVL is better in
the time scramble then than Vichy is and
I think that if you see this time
managed well it's going to be tough for
a cardinal
I think only five minutes I think
White's position is is is certainly
holdable and solid but you know you you
worry about the time as well I have one
important question for you Danny
oh um like this 26 they're either
nine f4 right when do you actually
consider taking it because I know my
first instinct is I can never take that
piece but then a knight is actually a
very good defender and by capturing it
it like at some moment you can either if
you know you take with the e pawn then
black can play h3 and open up the H file
in that way or if you take with the Jeep
pawn I could play g3 is black so that is
something that I honestly I have to
retrain my mind to think about because I
don't want to give up my bishop but
there are some little subtleties there
that can really help blacks attack yeah
the risk is that whatever that bishops
traded you can never get c7 back right
and that is the one kind of open door
for white if if the Queen side starts to
open up but yeah I mean if you even if
you use your imagination if something
fun happened like --tags --tags takes
and g3 okay this is like all of a sudden
I think something important Danny is
that we should not take on g3 is black
until we absolutely must right and
played yeah because now if you waste a
move let's say put 8 4 just to show that
really quickly and I put Bishop takes up
4 oh ok don't take into you must and the
point if you take with the e pawn on f4
I put h3 I believe and I'm just crashing
through the H file I'm not opening up
your Queen's defense or an escape square
for your King and if you take with the
jeep on on that 4 then I start with g3
and then I'm just also breaking through
over here on the Kings side it's ok I
don't know I'm just trying to come up
with ideas for black as you know when do
you take this bit and then enough for
because otherwise I don't see a way to
really crash through yeah in Queen age 6
is that whoa a4 was played what that was
really is a random suggestion I mean
Horner was like shaking his head like
you said a random suggestion and the car
was like
don't ever listen to Robert has his
random suggestions that's probably what
he's saying to himself right now whoa
rook AJ played I do see a curve in auras
yeah ruled to see that move Wow so what
was oh you know what it was Danny that
instead of rookie Jade
maxime shouldn't put h3
right away and if you you know that way
I'm throwing the breaker box if I take
you take the night first exactly and I'm
busted no matter how I recapture you
take with the Queen and it's lights out
Wow so so if h3 was played hey Karl
Whitney wouldn't even have the option to
take but this is that means you're
playing a position like this Robert or
something with the king honey - right I
mean what do you do here if you can't
take yeah this must be just losing in
like two moves so Brooke AJ played in
hákarl quickly puts the night on e -
still definitely worse but maxime just
missed a huge opportunity there and you
know we've seen a couple games now
back-to-back where firoozeh miss an
opportunity Maxime does I think Hikaru's
kind of a reputation as is helping him
here a little bit so Wade I don't know
people are people are believing his
tactical defensive ideas I guess and it
just strange also because Maxime is so
much time and you know danger in
classical events we've covered together
I'm very critical of players not using
more time when they have that time right
it's a little bit different in rapid
because you also are putting your
opponent in time trouble but I mean it
didn't feel like the moment where he
needs to rush rook h8 you could spend
five minutes on your clock still be way
ahead on time and then play brocade
shade and I mean honestly I'm benefiting
from the players reactions like seeing a
card freak out you led me to be like
okay there's something there what is it
and then I ch3 so that is why as
commentators is often easier we read
body language we get hints from the
players we can see the evaluation bar
even if we don't have engines ourselves
so I mean it's not like it was the
simplest thing in the world but you know
you should spend a little bit more time
there even if you don't ultimately come
up with the best move yeah it couldn't
agree more it it's you know it's
something we've seen Maxime despite
getting a time advantage I mean I guess
just speaking of recent memory you
wonder about how to actually use it
right and I think that he would argue
you know there's a lot of practical
factors that go into that and of course
he's much better at making those
decisions and executing than either of
us but just again as commentators seeing
positions where you feel like advantages
were maybe missed and or maybe just like
a it's like a lack of awareness that
this was a critical moment speaking to
an advantage against Alexander grishnak
from the candidates that maybe he didn't
quite convert despite a big lead on the
board and on the clock and then we
talked about the game with team
her Java from earlier in this event
where he didn't quite use his full time
- then maybe convert against in a
winning tactic that you actually spotted
and I'm just beyond it look at looking
at you know he's not using his time here
and his advantage isn't getting any
bigger yeah you love it now you're also
someone who would openly admit you use
too much time right you often get high
pressure but and I agree with you it's
way easier to sit and commentate because
you can just throw it ideas and if
they're wrong you take them back and
then you make a new idea so I understand
why Maxime is avoiding making any sort
of decision that cannot be changed right
they're taking that concrete approach
and saying right I'm gonna push my pawn
or capture on g3 then you just lose out
on other options so I get it you know
that kind of committal decision is hard
but he still is better and I mean Danny
I'm looking across these games here
yeah and Europe's chances to me it's
still our key window cuz it's not as
that needs it well but they're also
twiddling I think Fabiano's position is
getting better against Levon okay I
wasn't looking at that game at that
moment but you know okay you you steal
the but no let no no let's go to
Irina's game over here now with non is
like an easy we we haven't been here in
a while
you go it's funny because I thought you
were gonna say something and then I was
looking at the position and your face at
the same time those are two very you
know very deep things very very
beautiful things you know and I was I
was caught up I was not saying I hope
you were saying they're both appealing
because whites position here is clearly
appealing more space in the endgame
you're the black king on f6 well it
looks like it's good it's active it's
actually you know not necessarily in the
best spot because you can place a rook
up to e3 bow threatening to double over
t4 I don't know where threatening to
double an e file and play rook to f1 as
wellsworth t1 that King on f6 is maybe
not as well placed as you'd like and
white just has locked down the pawn
structure and I mean it's one of those
positions where I play the black slider
position like this and you just get
squeezed and you're like where can i
desperately find can i play here east
six comes to mind but you are dropping
upon some of these lines because of the
g5 pawn angle and then e6 maybe hanging
and c5 is a target so you have to
calculate these things quite deeply but
yeah that does give black some ideas for
counter play hmm but I mean it takes
here the risk of that of course is now
h6 is a serious problem and even even
further the f5 square becomes available
so I start thinking about things like
rookie five by the way hikaru and maxeen
Bashi in the garage talk about a very
very quick turnaround we have to go back
and show that they have already drawn
their game what what a surprise maxime
you know again I think that this showed
a little bit of maybe it helps explain
us a little bit further in terms of why
he missed his opportunity it feels like
maxime kind of had a hey a draw is a
good result coming in mindset because
and again this isn't to take anything
away from hit car we're maxing whatever
but there's objectively no real way to
deny that a form was was a huge blunder
we saw his car with reaction on camera
and h3 might have been just winning on
the spot for MBL and it's almost like
because of how quickly he played Robert
that he wasn't even looking for the win
and that's what happens when you give a
lot of credit to your opponent Carly
Nakamura is an amazing player you know
especially as we've seen in these online
events and the quick time controls but
the end of this it does sort of feel
like what has set up the fortress needed
yeah where you you're always ready for
any kind of h6g three by just
recapturing and where do you make
progress is black because you're not
checkmating the white king then white is
totally fine so i understand how after
missing your chance why you would make a
drive and so play this out because black
also doesn't really have any risk here
but i guess there's no way to make any
sort of progress so i understand sorrow
on camera i think he probably intended
to play ninety two maybe even before he
played a four and i think that that was
just a i mean we saw him reactor playing
a four and being like uh oh and now we
see him in the chat i don't think a
carro is trash he's saying i'm trash
he's not but obviously he knows he kind
of got away with one eight four was not
the right move order black misses an
opportunity and Accardo doesn't have to
be asked twice to set up the blockade
and so I agree with you objectively in
the final position we're not saying MBO
was better here anymore but it was just
interesting to see how Maxime used his
time advantage and and didn't quite
press on the h-file so right all right
well let's head over to the board to
battle we have a draw between hey Carmen
fel by the way those following the whole
event that means they drew both of their
matchups against each other in this
event but Bobby is this is why I said I
thought when you were saying Team Europe
chances were getting better I was gonna
complete that sandwich with teams Europe
chances are getting worse than we
thought they were because I think
Fabiano has started to open up things
for the rooks and I know we have a
protected past Poland to go with white
now but I don't know I just felt like
the the position is more open for the
rooks than it was earlier maybe I'm
missing something
no I think you're correct here and white
has two pawns and a knight for a rook so
just on paper that kind of compensation
it feels like hey why should be doing
okay but as you said things are opening
up for the rooks of a five here for
black is what I'm thinking about because
if you take on a five then I go rook a
eight I win back that pawn and then
there's a problem on c5 on a three and E
5 or all these split pawns from each
other so I'm with you but at the same
time I'm like I know black is better but
maybe LaVon has it in him to just kind
of settle down acknowledge that you're
worse and just try to create trades when
possible so
this past see pawn is sort of the hope
that you can save your position but
ultimately Dania I mean I'm totally with
you they buy really good for plan a5 has
been played now by Fabiano and again if
you're if you're following this from the
beginning of the round we were looking
at a position earlier that seemed like
it could be big trouble very quickly on
the Kings side but a combination of
maybe LaVon missing his chances and and
Fabiano defending resourcefully and now
we're we're getting closer to a position
that feels like it's gonna be hard for
our turf or LaVon so what does he what
does he have in mind here is the C pawn
kind of what you have to cash in on rook
to c3 Bishop a3 and then push him baby
yep then you start with Bishop f3 and
maybe it's not important but Bishop 3
these hits the rook on the 8th and gives
you ideas with c6 so you know one other
thing to keep in mind this is kind of
high level stuff but if white gives up
the e5 c6 and A three pawns for that B
Phi pawn um you have the two on two on
the King side some of those positions
you can still hold his white despite
being down a full extreme right so I'm
just trying to figure out the best
defensive strategy it's not easy to come
up with the idea but you want to think
about these things
ya know that's a really good thing to
kind of spy long term right if you just
imagine everything comes off but maybe a
rook versus a bishop or even a rook
versus a knight and just these pawns
black is pushing forever but is it
winning right is another question and
this Knight comes to e4 lavon's plan is
actually very straightforward now if the
knight gets the d6 it not only helps the
pawn robber to guard c4 so a quick
Knight d6 rook c3 and once again pushing
them that's that's kind of what Levon
hopes to do here and and we'll see if
Fabi can coordinate some kind of
pressure before that happens and there's
one more thing getting the 96 says it
attacks b5 so black would love to play
rook aid for d-day for and take on a3
but then I'm gonna take you on b5 in
return so that's right type of pawn
trade that I was sort of alluding to is
that I mean you can get my a pawn and
then maybe even get my E or C pawns
afterwards but if we start trading
pieces and there aren't that many pawns
remaining White's still
drawing chances someone said in chat
that LaVon has offered a draw and indeed
I'm confirming that on chess comm he has
indeed suggested that they end this
thing peacefully interesting maybe
trying to read what he thinks trying to
get a read is excuse me on how Fabiana
feels about the position probably who
can accept the drum because no wait well
no the two boards I think coming in as
black I mean you have a car with white I
mean you never know what's gonna happen
on these boards so I think that they
would all tell you they try not to think
about that and cuz they know they're
just gonna be in for a fight but but now
given where it's gone if a car was draw
is a good thing that he's like well I'm
gonna get a point here especially if
he's looking over at Wesley Soze game
with a nice giri which we haven't
checked on in a while but I think we
should okay so bring that one up for us
and whoa yeah the the might we predict
it actually happened if you're with us
the whole time where we left it after
Bishop a4 rook c7 indeed we had a trade
of the a7 for D Paul we were looking at
this and after rook c1 I had suggested
ideas of maybe Bishop b5 probably
probably the main point is that this
move is coming and and so knight c6 was
played to not just stop that but come
over here but I'm not sure that was the
best for Geary now in the Y position so
was so has gotten kind of out of Dodge
the king is uh
I just compared this position to where
it was before the rook landed on c1
right you're really worried that that's
exactly the thing that doesn't happen
and now I think so is has got to be
happy that the king is castled and he
hasn't lost any material yeah but I
think that Anisha is happy that this
position is just being traded off the
peas are being traded off you know with
minimum material remaining that this
looks like a position where I don't
really see any losing chances for black
and he's kind of doing his job in a
position where he never really had much
of the upper hand even if we slightly
preferred his position because if you
look at board four and I know we keep
saying that you know I keep looking at
the NHANES like needs getting back to me
is where Team Europe is winning this
match okay well I mean wouldn't that be
interesting if you have all three
drawers on the top three boards and it
does come down to the board for battle
the trade here I guess yeah I agree that
well maybe a niche didn't get some sort
of advantage when we were feeling the
heat for white yeah black black is
certainly not in danger of losing the
same game can only be a teensy-weensy
bit better so let's head over to crush
his battle with Sutton easy as you said
the rook ending looking better and
better for white I really didn't like G
takes h4 I mean we had to quickly go
back because hey Carlina BL had just
drawn their game but I was with you that
the keeping the tension I would have
looked for something dynamic Robert just
from a practical perspective of even if
I lose a pawn
I would love to clear away the the the
whole King side here and and try to be
down upon and draw the rook ending this
is like one of those positions were now
now your passive you're dealing with all
kinds of weaknesses and add a third red
mark on the c5 pawn please because well
I mean why not go all in here okay and
right now rook h3 checkmate is the
threat so right nunna is thinking can I
go King takes h6 because in the event
you've rook age three check then I block
with rook to age five but you have to be
careful then at some moment instead of
rookie somehow get like rook c8 the b3
pawn is hanging a lot of things are now
going in blacks favor so I would not
allow this kind of situation that's for
sure I would probably look to e3 yeah
sure sit tight
already finished rank rook it's it's you
know one thing in crushes favor or at
least in her defense is that this rook
on c6 is really useful not just for
guarding a six robber but it prepares b6
which if that trait happens that's one
less weakness and then you're Brooke
comes to b3 right you would when you're
at this stage or but we're saying again
you're just looking to trade weakness
for weakness if you can trade c5 for b3
and you know anything anything you can
do to get closer to an endgame where
even if white is up a single pawn that
may not be enough to win the rook ending
and you you have to be really accurate
here if your zag needs you to convert
this and one more thing on though in
addition to weak pawns is that White's
pawn is more outside so when you play g5
check let's say and we get a trade here
you're left with is a pawn for black
white has this Jeep on so in these end
games if you can imagine the rooks off
the board this immediately becomes a win
for white but as I use my Jeep on as a
decoy my King gobbles up you're a pawn
and then when we trade those pawns by
each taking each other's my King is
closer to the Queen's ax and the
remaining pollen so that is something
that is you need to keep in the back of
your head if you're a player in an
endgame having outside past pawns that
can be use as distraction is often to
your advantage
shocking we'll stay right here with the
ladies but you yogi has won again so big
big shocker not sure how this one
happened will will definitely highlight
all the chess moments that we don't get
to break down in live fashion everybody
during the break so if there's something
exciting and instructive to see we will
show it to you and a quick reminder of
course you can always head over to chess
calms live server or chess calm slash
events or whatever any device you're
using go ahead and watch the other games
if you'd like we're we're kind of zoned
in here to this full USA versus your a
battle and Danny go back for one move
please because I can see the eval barn
screen and after King takes h6
I thought that even bar dropped yep it
means that rook rook takes b3 was not a
good move so this is helping us out hey
Brooke age three checked and then rook
to c8 and then was a rook c8 or rook
takes me three now rook c8 oh and the
ideas of g5 you're just playing king of
seven and the king is still made it
yep it's kind of crazy I get any nuts
like there's some g7 stuff some but yeah
I mean you can get out of the mate but
the position is I don't know I mean
maybe you don't trade but yeah this is
complicated stuff I mean this is why
this is why it's super hard for them to
calculate right I mean the computer
obviously has an understanding that rook
age 3 followed by this really really
cool way to take advantage of the King
was best but understandable that neither
of these ladies saw that and
and now now's like needs he's just
getting nervous about the Kings position
and wants to what's the takeaway this
mating that idea and head back to the G
Foursquare yeah which is smart
especially when it's getting into a real
blitz game at this point where she does
not have too much time remaining and
avoiding checkmate now you also can
focus in on the other weaknesses for
black and the c4 pawn the a5 pawns
yeah they can be attacked but the past
pawn is the essential thing in this
position right the Jeep on is more
advanced Wesley so and a nice giri have
already drawn their game so just a flash
it real quick you saw the scoreboard
updated they agreed which wasn't a
surprise given where that game was
headed the the other game still going of
course Levon Aronian and Fabiano Caruana
may indeed prove to be the critical one
but or what if the critical was right I
mean Zack needs a crush right here or
wanna Aronian well it looks like we
might get some help and figure out
what's going on yeah and a little bit of
explanations too in terms of how how he
sees his team's chances so soon as were
we given the cue that we're ready we've
we've got the one and only Grandmaster
Maxime vache de Graaf step in it hey
Maxine hey Danny hey Robert hey Maxine
uh we I'd love to talk with you about
the finish that just happened with a car
oh but I think in the interest of what's
happening live right now and then that
we don't normally have
I'm obviously watching so what game war
talk about quite well since my missed
win so yeah but um guys think no no it's
a very good position obviously I mean
too many weaknesses for blacks when on
using the pound b7 or CH fighting I mean
that's a big weaknesses because of
course right if you go this face and
hook each one of h7
this should be over as well so I mean
basically in end games you know as
always active pieces come for some
things
pretty sure this is gonna be a win for
us okay in 11th position was a bit
worrying but now should be I mean within
drawing margin with this powerful
opponent c6 adding to fantasy lands not
sure exactly
all but I cannot believe that it can be
worse I mean it can defend she goes
because it's not I mean
zombies and drop but Maxine Kenny Kenny
just play c7 here it's right turn right
so season a top 55 there but can I go
rook eight eight and yeah but then I can
double down the sea fine
ah so you're just because the point
everybody get spawn off seven because
there's Nighy a check for king in the
king and the rook so I just want to
point it out for everybody but it does
feel like black is a little tied down
right I mean I would consider keeping
the pronounce a 6 for now because it's
supported
yeah so I would go probably something
like a chain just give some breathing
room for my king
going into h2 it's apparently not a
great move but don't engine maybe we
should not allow d4 I don't know run
more baby yeah
what's on ITA at the end of the world
but it's true that if we could keep this
night on d6 it would be nice so I don't
know seems like it should be audible but
I mean this feels like the critical game
because I really don't see Nana right
it's pointing out without winning it
again it's going down this road yeah
foxy one probably okay 855 okay seven uh
with the idea of shades this is very
nice alright Bishop away from webserver
I see yeah and you have to be careful
the doctor walks it to you King G Street
probably and you don't get mated right
my favorite three of four is
completely fine and if you cut this one
we have seven obviously I mean CN games
are aa very Jewish yeah and you know I
mean we do have two games lots of if we
go back to the other board really
quickly dear let's go back for a second
but well this looks like I mean this
should be winning but even I did manage
to find some counter play but I don't
think she's in time right
time pressure obviously setting occupies
with the idea of hookah c5 would be my
plan instinct after stopping the
progress of you know blacks work a stock
is sitting does it use up waking at 5:00
because I should be five of your next
move but if you go at five simply and
then would see seven you're pushing back
on me over
okay so sort of the same idea I feel and
if you differ you know you can take on
g43 yeah Oh actually here you can go 57
check because of the king g6 you've rook
c7 and then black is completely study
for with a lot of me yeah now this is
over yeah I read a big trouble you go
like there's a hook d7 f5 and just wrote
e7 King GA will be the only move then
you don't even bother with a queen side
ya know so Maksimir you feel a little
bit better now that you're watching
these games finish out here yeah it was
a bit frustrating because my position
felt very good and I missed this one
killer blow that you probably survived
but the thing was I was always
considering age 63 right and forever and
I was trying to make it work it never
seemed to work and I completely forgot
that h3 was legal and zhonya this is a
way to to break up an insert on the King
site so it was yeah bit weird once I
found out that this was the win but I
didn't figure it out Jinja came up night
I saw it but it's after when I got some
remarks from the team captain the team
captain respond to you I mean I really
should've found this and yeah it's a
pity because I was actually playing
quite a good game in some you know
typical right to don't sing so once in
this by the way something yes something
has transitioned over here and me yes
whatever I mean for now is a king going
back to gcrh to Amina there is no real
way for black about this at all loses
this fortress yeah but everybody just
easiest fortress you can even ever get I
think
right back here you can keep the roots
you can exchange them you can be passive
you can try to bring your king up like
h4 is fine but you could keep your king
on h2 and just wait with the bishop on
the long diagonal
yeah and the other game is about to
actually conclude so if LaVon I was a
big flow yeah yeah no so I was a bit
frustrated and I offered to draw because
I couldn't find a way to progress and I
just sucked
yeah let's offer draw before I blunder
but of course actively I should probably
still keep on but I felt like so much
was going away the nice
so that Levin's position was not it was
a bit more dangerous than I thought
at first and I was bit questioning my
decision but I think it turned out to be
quite a good one so awful the chip
captain four forgives me or maybe even
Stella boys made for my you know four
sites I do have a question though
because going into this match is some
sort of must-win because then now you
could show your own destiny were you
thinking that maybe I'm bored for that
was your biggest advantage Nana's like
an easy with the white pieces or here's
all focusing on your own matchups
individual well that's what I thought
but you know in a team event you have to
to check on boards so that's what I did
continuously I was held by the fact that
I was doing they were on the truck and
also on the positions I was sort of in
control of my destiny in that game and
[Music]
yeah maybe I am many still of course bit
of a bother that I missed this
is this idea with HC again but also it
helped that we knew that Tutu was not
the end of the world like we wanted to
win to match of course but but to to is
also fine and fun fact I think this is
also doing black as a h-bomb
you know when you get this King on g1
and the bishop hands along diadem yeah
uh-huh so h4g spheres this is why 11 is
paying for this I think because
otherwise it I mean I think it makes no
sense to go for this but at the same
time it's clear draw so like h5 probably
should be forcing it like g5 kimchi for
all the king is he could be annoying
he's like Angie no I mean before cuz
your team is the kimchi okay
this is gonna be a draw here because the
H value but attracting is fee right away
could be sort of a lot of them and then
g5 in the King is cut off yeah yeah so
yeah I think it's just gonna stay for me
one I would have kept the phone on g20
straight but and it's the main worry I
mean okay I know it should be a job but
the only outside chances the g3 becomes
a target right that somehow yeah yeah
it's very instructive actually because
most people would brought the King h3
and go forward but then you allow the
black King into f2 so instructive
fortress that my team has been telling
everybody even if black were given
handed in H pawn it's still a drug
because white keeps the black King out
yeah and the only with a bishop I mean
apart from you know them do a bishop is
cheat too because I know people check
happens yeah fun I mean it's still
possible that this would still be a draw
but
yeah she'll be shot before I guess would
be the easiest yeah this would be the G
pardon or sir yeah that that's
instructive there this this pawn on g3
combined with the LightSquared Bishop is
is all the blockade no of course
okay I mean I if we expect him that live
on doesn't choose this and yeah I mean
dish of g6 and h5 once you get it's like
it's easier when you have one to support
the bishop otherwise it could get a
little tricky but I mean although it's
10 seconds increment you're probably
fine but with the points for the bishop
it's just right
well king of three is was the only idea
there but even here there's there's no
real way to get the pawn by force
because hey no kimchi for you you get it
I came for okay keep the bishop out of
each module
that's that's why you're my dad right
there because of little like that no but
still still a dead Joe so like yeah a
bit confused on this cast why I didn't
go G to H E and just move this Bishop
like that's what I was doing bullets
maxime he actually his technique that's
why he wanted to show you that that
excellent Armenian school chess no no
you might have a point that at some
point blood gets g4 and you never know
but yeah and I guess that's my cue to to
be a team meeting so we won't keep
obviously secure spots in Sebastian's
give captain Gary are our best obviously
and and and tell him not to be too harsh
on you you know you didn't have the
foresight of where this good match was
headed apparently so yes apparently
don't tell him to be nice to my dad very
lucky you know Gary to be nice to nice
to my dad alright Maxine we'll see you
later
Maxine alright MBL tuning in there which
is awesome and now he goes and joins
team captain garry kasparov as they
review and talk about their next match i
mean certainly it's not over yet but
that was that was not the way Team USA
wanted round nine to go known as you
read this graphic in front of you about
the qualification heading into today
Team Europe advances with a super fun
with a win over USA step one check and
now they beat the rest of the world team
they're in so there's no discussion now
about who controls their destiny it's
all about Team Europe and for the USA
not only do they need Team Europe not to
win that match they need to beat team
China a team that hasn't dropped a
single match yet I mean I just don't see
it happening for the American squad well
it's it would be it would be the the
upset of the of the event Team USA now
has to beat Team China what do they do
here or does is there a is there a
lineup change do they do they throw in
someone who's been sitting out and gets
a chance of glory like Eleni or
Dominguez Perez not to say
Wesley so might be the best person to
take on you young G but that has been a
board that
the team China has dominated all event
that being of course as we as we're
saying board three you young he is the
guy that I think everyone's talking
about right now a Team USA how do we
beat this guy where's the lineup change
coming from what can we do but either
way we have drama here we have almost
19,000 of you with us across multiple
platforms so don't go anywhere round 10
is coming up but Robert and I will have
a breakdown of some of the games we
didn't we didn't catch all your reza
firoozeh beats Sergey Karjakin and in a
spectacle we'll take a look at that one
of course we'll give final final recaps
in terms of the critical moments that
we're Team USA versus Team Europe round
10 and much more coming up from the feed
HS comm online Nations Cup in just a
minute
[Music]
and as we return here with the feed HS
calm online Nations Cup it is our very
very great pleasure to bring on the the
goat the the greatest women's chess
player of all time Grandmaster Judah
Pulgar now a feed a vice president as
well Judith thank you so much for being
here with us I'm happy to be here I
don't even know where to start it's an
honor to have you obviously you um you
have a you have a lot we could ask you
about your your in cooperation and as a
VP at feed a helping do some amazing
things with chess you said yourself
you've been watching the events so and
we know you're a very strong chess
player maybe you have some chess
thoughts and I just want to say that
first of all as you look at what's
happening right now in the world of
online chess so many huge events
happening the Magnus Invitational this
event here right there's more to come as
a former chess player you look at the
landscape of online chess growing does
it does it excite you does it does it
make you excited for where the future of
the game is going and the the growth
we're experiencing right now online
well absolutely actually already for
quite a long time I was quite actively
expressing my views within FIBA and
elsewhere as well that I think online
chess is something has to be big and has
to be brought up as a very unique
opportunity for the chess world and for
everybody for chess enthusiasts as well
as chess coaches and just professionals
and also obviously I'm also very much
favored and making steps and trying to
move extra value for the chess in
education so it isn't something very
important I believe that of course the
days we are living right now due to the
pandemic it's very unfortunate for the
world and obviously it gives very hard
time for many of the people and many of
the parts in the world but at the same
time for chess it is something
exceptional lucky and I think we have to
be phrasing this opportunity and all the
chests lovers must be very happy that
chess is a game which is more than 1500
years old the heritage it has and and
that actually we can enjoy the online
tournaments webinars everything so well
and I think there is lot to be improved
but I really like the way you're doing
now for the and I'm not only saying this
because because I'm gonna show now but I
I really like that you paid a lot of
attention on the on the graphics and on
the quality stuff and I think there is
lot to be improved for players for all
technical issues and of course I don't
want to get around on the topic of the
problem as well cheating is something
always there and this is the main
problem of the online competition I
believe and this is the very most of the
people have at the same time I believe
that it's very important in the world to
have trust in each other and cheaters
are always there and offline events also
it's a very serious crisis and and
problems and opportunities so for the
people who want to ruin
the image of chess and and the great
taste and for the people who have the
passion it is a problem but I think many
of us have to do things steps whatever
possible to do something against it but
I think for now we have to enjoy what
they have well yeah that's I think well
said there you did and you know I see
the sign for chess connects us behind
you so you do so much for the game of
chess both as a role model as a that won
an elite player yourself but can you
tell everybody a little bit about what
you do with chess connects us and how
that's operating during copa90
well chess connects us is our slogan
because that's how I grow up since I'm H
5 so more than 30 years by now nearly 40
that I mean everything connected with me
it was with chess and we created a
global chess festival which is an every
second Saturday of each October we have
an event huge event in Budapest but also
at the same time I'd like to encourage
everywhere every little part of the
world to have their own chess event
chess related activity to connect to our
event so my dream is to have thousands
of different locations inspired with the
chess and giving some chests activity
there and this is something I think we
can easily do we just need a little bit
synchronizing all of the energy we put
into chess and this year we still plan
to have it on the 10th of October as
planned but definitely we are going to
move on for the online platform more
actively than last year and you've
already been doing a lot of amazing
things online and I applaud you of
course the the Pagar chess festival that
has grown into the global chess festival
has been just an amazing thing to
appreciate and watch I do did you
touched on so many great things on there
on your opening statements there on the
things we need to address the great
things about the growth of the game and
dealing with cheating and there was only
one other chest thing I wanted you to
touch on which is that we've been
sitting here watching probably the two
best active women's chess players right
Hoey fallen and you and june who just so
happened say play for this
team right as the strongest women's
chess player in history what do you see
when you look at those two and and what
are your thoughts in terms of how
impressed you are obviously how unfair
it seems at times with the two of those
those two and just if you would give
your thoughts on how important that's
been for Team China to see the growth of
women's chess in China and those two
ladies leading the way well China is
really killing everybody it seems like
they are really on the top of the world
for already quite a few years and this
event is not an exception it is very
clear the last decade was for China in
chess and they always they had really
great players and they have a good
attitude and of course they have an
exceptional training it seems so
psychologically they are also extremely
strong it is nice to see back we find in
in action I don't know what are her
plans how more active is it going to be
when there are offline events as well
but it is nice to see that there are
opportunities for ladies more
opportunities for example as in this
event to see top players ladies to
compete I think it gives it adds a
little bit of the competition definitely
you know exactly how I feel about them
in chess in general I think we have to
inspire girls parents teachers coaches
in order that they should have a mindset
when they see a little girl of seven
years old very talented then that's my
dream that the chess coach comment will
be not that value can be ladies world
champion but to have the same and
comment as let's say when you think that
the boy can be like Magnus Carlsen and I
think this is very important that not
only me giving this message but also the
top lady players who I know that they
fight very much they work very hard but
I think there are quite a few messages
which would be possible to give by demo
so like I don't think they are training
as much as I did and I don't think they
had such a support from parents point of
view nor from the coaches point of view
so where to put the
the goals right and I think this is what
I feel that I want to do a lot in this
direction that they simply don't don't
limit the possibilities and the dreams
of the girls yeah well said last
question before we let you go have to
ask do you miss it
do you miss playing in these elite
events are you still enjoying retirement
no actually I'm very busy I'm I'm not
missing it because I know I was there
for more than 30 years comparatively
which I know exactly how much effort and
energy you have to put into the everyday
training to be fit for the competition's
and this is why I think I'm much more
realistic than a dreamer from this point
of view and and I know what it takes to
be on the top at the same time I'm very
happy if I have some spare time to
follow chess of course now it's even
more fun but I'm very happy to do the
global chess festival to run my
foundation to do a lot further how
educators can be involved in education
in Hungary very actively or more
actively than we do now and
internationally I think I can do much
more on those fields well Judy I just
have one question for you leftist were
you recruited to play in this event like
was there any interest I mean would you
have wanted to play actually I have to
tell you that I did got an invitation to
play more over more funny requests to
play on the ladies world so the person
who asked me definitely I don't think
that he likes to listen no answers for
sure well we all miss you as fans but
appreciate and agree with your comments
there that what you're doing as an
ambassador
just as important more important than
ever right now for the game and it's
it's so great to have you have you doing
what the work you're doing so Judit
thank you so much for being here we
appreciate your time and we're gonna say
goodbye to you and cue up an exciting
thing for all the fans don't go anywhere
we're gonna be right back enjoy this
world premiere breaking music video here
by by hookah who is a a chess artist and
we're gonna we're gonna say goodbye to
JUnit thank you for being here and be
back in a few minutes
thanks to that bide unit
[Music]
just you
you better
[Music]
[Applause]
and we are back here once again with the
feet a chest come online nations come
now joined by a very special guests all
those of you watching
we're just treated to a world premiere
music video by the one and only hooga
hooga musica calm herself who got first
of all great song and tell us what
inspired you with your with your new and
newest and and latest single here
because I want to be present with you I
am very delighted for this invitation
thank you so much and this song is my
fourth a testing song inspired by chest
this time is a bit more personal it has
a romantic story behind it so to say it
compares the ending of really complex
relationship with a chess game a chess
game where you think your opponent
should already resign you know the title
can be misleading because it's you
better resign and some people say like
that's not very encouraging for you know
for someone to say like you better
resign like you should be more in a mode
to say like you should never resign you
know but it's not meant for you to say
to yourself it's meant for you to say to
your opponent you know you many times
you want to say during a game like guy
I'm gonna win this you better resign you
know but in chess and there is no much
opportunity to say out loud the emotions
that are going on inside you it seems
that chess is a very silent game and
very you know that you're behaving and
you have everything under control but
inside of you there is a rollercoaster
of emotions and with my song that is
what I try to express the restraint
emotions the passion of chess inside of
you and inside of you you want to say
just you better resign that's great ohoo
guy I am curious I'm sure everybody is
what is your own chess background like
I've been involved with chess in a very
young age I I belong to the Chilean
chess Foundation and I collaborated to
create the women national chess
tournament that is until now but that
was back in 2007 so all my life I've
been in a in contact with grandmasters
and the history of chess and love with
kappa blanka and alec you know and they
just reading about all these wonderful
tournaments and watching chess books and
chess matches and very close friend also
with top a chess players even though I
am an amateur chess player and a
passionate competitive eye Madrid chest
and I really I really also I studied
chess and I try to play as many
tournaments as I can I love classical
tournaments the last years I've been
studying more theory and improving and I
play a lot of chess online I'm addicted
to fossil rush I am a big chess fan so
I'm trying to do with these songs just
to make more people fall in love with
chess and notice everything that is
happening because we're millions we are
big chefs family all over the world just
as music chess is a universal language
but I think that chess is a little bit
hidden from society and from culture and
we have my stones I'm trying to do
something to to make it easier for
people to reach out it's amazing I mean
obviously I mean it did chest level
amateur chess player or not what you're
doing is growing the game and it's
fantastic to watch every I'm a fan I
know that a lot of people appreciate
what you're doing and watching watching
your music explode all over the internet
and so on that note tell everybody if
you would please where they can follow
you obviously we see hookah music accom
but anything special you want to share
about where they can stay attached I
know you also have a fan club on chess
calm but tell everybody where they can
follow you and how they can get involved
with your with your community yes my
friends if you want to listen to my
previous jazz music songs okay
Blanka tactical isolated pawn Caruana
own anna and many other songs and
products to come you can find them on
film and you can
follow me on Instagram I'm very active
at the musica on Twitter on Facebook
like in all platforms right now I have a
twitch channel which I am dreaming
Cheska okay and I invite you to join in
also it's my channel also hula music the
way I hope that you enjoyed this new
video and looking forward to show you
some more cool guys one last question
for you and it's important one I know
Danny is always itching to make a chest
song would you make one with Danny
wrench
of course I would Robert Robert here's
me in the in the the behind-the-scenes
making-of my own lyrics about the chest
show we're about to do to some random
pop song of the day but Robert you just
outed me but thank you I would love to
make a song with you whoo good and thank
you so much thank you so much for being
here and and best of luck with the new
song and and your and your your whole
career thank you so much thank you and
congratulations for this wonderful
tournament online Nations Cup it's a
really beautiful graphics beautiful
transmission beautiful commentary and
thank you so much chestnut come and see
us were endorsing my video it's really
it means a lot to me thank you so much
thank you so much thank you
that was the one and only hygge you can
go to hookah música calm as we said and
find out all that she has to offer that
was that was fun and not something you
see every day on our chest show but it
is interesting and different right it's
it's unique what she does for chess and
and in music as an artist so so cool
stuff so Robert we we are gonna be
getting set to head into the final round
we've got the standings there on the
left that everyone can see of course
team China Team Europe and Team USA are
the big three left that we're talking
about of course China has already
secured their spot in the super final
Team Europe just leapfrog Team USA if
you missed it what around it was in
round nine all kinds of drama and now
they control their own destiny Team
Europe will be facing off with team
world the same lineup we just saw - a
nice giri young Christopher Duda back in
he'll be taking on bass Emma mean
they're on board three and that's an
interesting choice I think that a nice
giri almost looked to kind of prove the
theory that Robin and I were talking
about as far as why he was in the lineup
by team captain garry kasparov he was in
there for one reason which is to hold
against Wesley so and kind of taking
advantage of anisha's experience against
Wesley stylistically and so now young
Christophe Duda back in the face against
Boston I mean and Danny and you see
Nonna's like needs he in there you have
to leave her in she has the hot hand she
played a great game against Irina crush
so none is like me is he going to take
on a tough opponent dinara stuff like a
sofa but I'd like what you said there
about you know the trade-off that Gary's
making between Anish as solid may be
used in when the black piece is to hold
off his elite opponent and then putting
JKD and perhaps try to score victory
with white and then of course it comes
down to the x1 so Team Europe kind of
shown first here on purpose because they
are the ones in control of their own
destiny destiny but if they should not
get the win let's talk about team China
versus Team USA obviously it is a
matchup where USA is the underdog just
based on the performance of China but
hey look at that
you young Yi is not in the lineup for
China I if I'm if I'm Team USA that's a
little bit of a fist pump there
didn't want to face that guy who just
can't seem to be stopped on board three
yeah he has been the superstar of this
event he has had a meteoric rise of
sorts and just winning every game it
feels like but I also note that I'm
bored for Joe when June is in and know
how you thought so you see that board
for decision you have you're spoiled for
choice we know that both of these
players are excellent but it is
interesting to note that perhaps Yvonne
will she play again in the Super Final I
assume so but we haven't seen her in
this matchup as n pawn said in the words
of Lloyd Christmas so you're saying
there's a chance
for Team USA and again it does seem like
I don't know I don't believe that it's
quite the the legendary Dumb and Dumber
reference of one-in-a-million but it is
obviously it's a tough it's a tough task
for Team USA no doubt none of them would
deny it we know team China is so good
but these guys have all played each
other before we know there's a there's a
potential any time when it comes to
high-level chess preparation anything
can happen so yeah I gotta I gotta make
a correction here Ewing he is indeed in
the lineup or graphic is incorrect so
just to clarify for everybody the lineup
for China will be Dingley Ren Wang Hao
Yu yang Jie and Joo and Joon so they are
using Yuki ng of course here he is
playing so wellness man he gets the
white piece against Wesley so I just
wanted to make that clear astok was very
glad you interrupted me because that is
information we want to correct and no
reason to dig deeper into that storyline
now that we know he is playing so it is
ding li Ren obviously Wang Hao Yu young
yi and women's world champion human jun
so we're gonna take a very very quick
break here as we get set for round 10
when we come back we will do our final
previews final matchup prediction show
you quickly a great game that again was
all heroes of perugia a victory over
sergey karaoke and we will deliver on
that promise we promise but thanks for
being with us here are some amazing
interviews with Judit Polgar and hooga
hooga musica comm check it out Robin and
I will be back with round 10 the feed HS
comm online Nations Cup in just a minute
[Music]
you
and we are back here getting set for
round 10 of the feat HS comm online
nation's Cup excuse me it's been
it's been quite the break here great
guest and quite the week this was quite
the game robber probably one of the most
exciting games that really didn't get
enough attention from us and I wanted to
start it right here where the tide just
started to shift we had talked about the
position earlier where what was black
gonna do to kind of untangle and
coordinate the king and fix the problem
but firoozeh had a different idea in
mind as as Sergei backed up he said no
no actually my king is his right where
it needs to be along with the rook and
the whole direction of this game just
started to shift with black going for an
attack pause me when you see something
interesting but when he played g5 here
this hold this this whole game became
one that Sergei just didn't quite know
what to do he started shuffling the king
and queen and got in big trouble and it
shows some great skills by Ally race' to
say I don't need to play King aged 7 to
get my work out that way I'm gonna be
active first then bring my King into the
center despite the fact there's so many
heavy pieces on the board he says that
King a safe and sound of how active my
pieces are and my opponents pieces don't
have the same room to work with so
really nicely done here by erisa yeah
and you know again it's not the game
that we focused a lot on because of the
the important nature of the team Europe
versus Team USA battle but this might
have been the game of the round right
that that gets gets a lot of attention
later on as far as video reviews and
those sort of things because what it
what are just great way for him to have
a heads up like you said he he shifts
gears and brings the King back into the
center and turns the Kings side into an
attack for black rather than white
Sergei doesn't quite know what to do he
was also under time pressure and
eventually firoozeh breaks through with
this very very nice chief for idea looks
like they're saying taking the knight
was a blunder meaning they as in the
artificially intelligent overlords that
we have no choice but to surrender to
apparently white does have other ways to
try to hold the position instead of
taking the knight one of them is king of
one keeps it a little bit more tense the
other is this very engine move on
looking at b3 the ideas I guess if you
take it Robert now you can take care I
don't know I don't really like you
computers well Danny you also don't like
Queens in each one do you I why would
you do that it's not necessary in front
of all the people here I would say
they're fans but I don't know that
they're fans let's be honest they don't
have anywhere else to go right now in
the world right was your Jimmy for that
damn so I am feeling the same pain
you're feeling I just laugh about it
afterwards yeah Queen on h1 was was the
infamous chess comm lost to chess bra in
our team match battles but yeah Sergey
also doesn't like the Queen on h1 and
after h2 just resigns obviously Brooke
to g1 is coming and if the Queen takes H
- there's Queen rook takes h4 and shut
the front door
it's what Sergei Kuryakin is unable to
do unable to shut the front door here
that Queen is actually trapped over
there really nicely done his performance
there by Ali Riza firoozeh and I mean
he's such a strong player we may have
overlooked it because of what we're
looking at in the standings I'm speaking
of I mean we know that China is going
through but as we have done one round
remaining Europe has the clear path
forward but USA sells a chance well
let's bring that up as Roberts talking
about it let's show everybody what it
will be in this in this final round now
obviously the two bolded options at the
top are are kind of the the control your
own destiny option especially for europe
europe advances were the win over the
world period it doesn't matter what
happens in USA's match versus china if
europe can get the job done and win
their match obviously team world looking
for a chance to play spoiler from that
perspective and help the team USA just
by playing the best chess they can but
it would take a lot they would need to
draw or beat europe and as we can see
the USA advances with a win over China
and a Europe draw or lost two world
there is the very unlikely scenario
hence why it's not bolded that the USA
draws China and advances if Europe loses
so Europe would have to lose and not
draw their match now you pointed out
something Robert I'm gonna let you take
the wheel on at the break that's an
important
thing to note about the the tiebreaker
that occurs in terms of tonal match
point so let's let's bring up our tie
break break down and let you go through
not just the rules of our tiebreaker but
also what that means for the exact
scenario here for Europe and USA well
you see that topic number one is board
points is the app you accumulate you
aggravate the individual players results
and right now Europe and USA they're
tied with board points and because
Europe is ahead of USA in match points
that means if they end up on the same
number of match points then USA well
just by nature of the math here will out
score on the edge of boards Europe and
thus if they end of the time match
points USA goes through that means that
Europe will always to keep an eye out
hey can we actually draw this mattress
USA winning and I think Europe just has
to focus on their own match do their
best they are the favorite over the rest
of the world but that's dangerous
territory for them yeah let's let's run
through the the match upstairs you said
they need to focus on their matchup if
they get the job done by beating team
world the rest is literally history but
if they draw let's talk again team China
versus Team USA if they draw and Team
USA wins that is enough for them to
leapfrog because as you pointed out by
definition of the math that Team USA
wins they have gained more total board
points and they would leapfrog them so
we will you and I are gonna be acting
like leap frogs as we jump all over the
map here because all eight games between
these two matchups China and USA and
Europe and world are gonna matter to us
so we're gonna do everything we can to
follow them super closely of course the
third matchup and the first one that's
actually getting underway is this
particular one between Russia and and
India not the most critical matchup of
the round but remember of course it's
still high-level chess and if there's a
great game there we will spy it and
maybe show it to you when we can but I
think we've got to start here we've got
the the board one matchups right ding li
Ren vs. Aiko Nakamura as far as the
board matchup of China and USA and then
you have the beast of Leone as he's
known on chess calm Maxime Bosch a
magrav vs. team over job of
and I mean we're going to focus on these
eight games as you point out Danny and
when I think about these lineups and I
think about first the USA versus China
match I'm thinking about board four it's
always coming down to Joe and June or oh
you fond in this case you and June taken
Irene a crush just that's where your
advantages and for the Europe press rest
of the world I mean that's again it's
more of a toss-up on board for but the
higher boards favor the team Europe of
course there's tons of other games too
we'll just quickly flash them you know
Levon Aronian has taken on all the races
of Arusha I mean this is team world
versus Team Europe excuse me and and
well this will also be absolutely huge
if faroush is is somehow playing spoiler
here as white and and upsetting
upsetting Team Europe that's not what
they want
Fabiano Caruana going back to the old
number one as they say he is the world's
leading expert on the Petroff but guess
who might be number two right behind him
or baby number one depending if you ask
him Wang he'll Wang Hao Yu yang Jie the
Chinese players they love themselves a
good Petroff and well they often have
Fabiano Caruana
and his team to thank for some of the
new lines that are dug up and and we
look at this position what has these CC
pawns which to some say hey this is
Robert always say a pawns best friends
another pond so these double pawns
probably aren't good but you do have a
semi-open d-file some pressure down the
D file and if I can eventually play c4
is white then this pawn on d6 becomes a
target and not to mention some kind of
Knight g5 with some pressure on the
black king side as well so I typically
like these positions for white but
Fabiano Caruana let me ask you Danny do
you think there might be a moment where
he's just like wait a second I played
this from black side as well I kind of
like it for black you know what I what I
will say is there's gonna be moments
where we have to reference all the
different games Fabiano has played as
black and white right now we will in a
rapid affair not have a ton of time to
give you an opening theory lesson here
but if anybody's curious I mean a pretty
sure this exact position did occur in
the 2018 World Championship match
between Fabiano car won and Magnus
Carlsen or at least this something very
similar to this I mean you and I I feel
like we were just talking about a couple
games in this line from the candidates
so I mean you already highlighted one of
the key features right will the pond get
to c4 and make d6 weak does the pawn on
see
we get met by D five and black fixes all
of it and opens up more lines Queen a5
is an idea as you said Knight g5 is an
idea here and and and that could be
something black worries about with all
the tricks that come but you know one
how taking a second to think because he
knows that even just a subtle move order
difference here bishop afford not the
move Fabiano has played every time in
this position is enough for him to make
sure he pauses and now he decides d5 to
try to hold back c4 so sorry I didn't
quite answer your question there partner
as far as just Fabiana want to be black
I don't think so but I know that Fabiano
in truck Bobby Yellin oh I trust in
these positions I'll say that but in one
how I also trust okay you know feel like
if III don't disagree with you at all we
are on the same page this is gonna this
is gonna be a theoretical battle that
everyone pays attention to and look at
this we saw Knight g5 Bishop to g4
hitting the rook on d1 yeah and F 3
closes off that bishop and white often
you know wants to go for g4 h 4 pressing
those pawns forward because you've
castle on opposite sides of the board
that's a dynamic that we can't look past
and look at this Bishop to d7 trying to
make a claim I guess the night on g5 is
not new is there some kind of h7 check
right now or 90 h7 uh dirty dog dirty
dog just one nine eight seven let's do
it and just take on h7 and you take
anything d5 and in the end you have
Queen h5 so the bishop can't move
because Down Goes the first lady Wow
wait is happiness is this prep by
Fabiano or a blunder by Wang hell cuz
now I think it's caused it's a blunder
it's gotta be a blunder but it's also
showing that these are the these are the
leading experts here and again I kind of
smelt a small rat when Wang Hao slowed
down on Bishop before just at least to
say that this was clearly at least a
move order he wasn't ready for because
these guys don't pause and think in the
openings that they're the best at for no
good reason because they know they'll
need their time later when the novelty
is eventually on court and then he plays
d5 and I wonder if that was a mistake
because because by the way on f3
what were you gonna do play Bishop h5
and allow the pawns to come at you with
Tempe I guess he was nervous and now
Fabiano might be winning on the spot
here and I'm
wonder if won't have mixed up his lines
or what's going on here because this
just looks like a big problems take that
pond age seven and you get away with it
this is this is crazy I mean I was
already gonna say before before the
confirmation if there was a blunder that
if you were just taking an objective
step back and saying well you know your
team has to win would Fabiano say I'm
happy with the positioning I chose I
think yes and then all of a sudden that
eval bar we see that you know plus two
according to the engine started to creep
up I'm like yet regardless of the
practical factor let's get concrete up
in this I'm in shock because I never
expect wong hau of all people to blunder
in this way and I mean does Fabia don't
not see it he must see it he's fine
firming there's no way he doesn't see
this he's confirming and double-checking
he also has a small time advantage we're
not gonna go anywhere until Fabi uncorks
this but I'm spying these other games
again if you're just tuning in you can
hear the hype and our voice oh man I am
excited for round 10 here of the online
Nations Cup the USA has to defeat China
for a chance to move on to the Super
Final and Fabiano is trying to lead the
way right now and you know our daily
question was you know what will it take
to beat China in the Super Final it
might take a blunder from wang hao on
move you know 15 or whatever move and
you know it's scary how good they are
but this is what happened you make an
oversight and if your opponent punishes
you it's over and Fabiano was so
concentrated i found his cameras frozen
for a second young the young
international master christopher you
hanging out in the chest TV chat you can
head out over there and hang out with
some title players if you want fans
chatting on YouTube and twitch but
Christopher you says and I think he's
right that Fabiana was actually
calculating the difference between
Bishop takes h7 and Knight takes h7
because Knight takes can be met by rook
e8 and maybe the attack obviously white
stole a pawn but the attack isn't
rolling so he's wondering whether he can
justify the forcing move the check right
and it aligned like this though there's
still rook e8 at the end of it but then
there's this move and so I think I think
Fabien was thinking because it's kind of
messy right he's trying to make sure he
he he executes the right way and it's a
good point and it's one that we
criticize Maxime on in the previous game
although Maxime came on in degrees like
he just never came
my mind which is it which happens we all
have these moments in chess where
there's an idea that just really just
doesn't come to us and we're after the
game like of course I should have seen
that but here won't how it looks like
he's seen it because he looks very
unhappy yeah and we've seen him in this
pose for a while and just like how can I
make this mistake the good news for
China is you've already qualified so you
your place is safe but let me ask you
Danny would you rather play Team USA or
Team Europe if you're the Chinese team
oh where are you suggesting are you
suggesting what I think you're
suggesting I'm not at all suggesting
that because that would not be okay I'm
asking you just generally speaking okay
well I mean okay like I don't think it I
don't think I was implying anything
super unethical or substr fuge I mean
you talk about NFL a lot of things
people talk all the time but no dude
really I'm sorry about you I know I see
he doesn't see it whoa we're gonna blog
how and how happy he is look at that he
just like leave back and grabbed a
Gatorade and said this this almost
blunder is brought to you by coca-cola
or whatever he's got there oh my gosh oh
my gosh Fabiano misses
holy cow to use the totally PG term that
Christopher you just said in the chess
TV chat I'm not gonna drop the holy
bleep I wanted to say okay again Knight
takes 87 is winning it's winning ladies
and gentlemen we're not kidding it's
winning and I'm not kidding I'm a poet
and I didn't know it ceefor by Fabiana
what in the world I don't know what to
say because it was just available to me
now black didn't play d4 in all these 97
ideas in the holes it's gone but the
whole tactic was based on d5 hanging
everybody whether you take with the
bishop or the knight the point is this
works because of this
the d5 point is hanging
what I mean I'm very hot right now and
what is still better here for the for
the record you know the bishop one at
four is good by playing d4 it's very
committal as it tends to be when you
have pawn to d5 and c5 whenever you push
up on it gives me the e4 square for
example but long how was the happiest
man alive to see that c4 played boy was
that a natural reaction we saw again he
leaned back like I do after saying
something you know awkward that I'm
gonna regret happens about ten times in
a show and I lean back and take a sip of
this mug let's go ahead and move on to
the next game Picaro and Dingley brent
here making of awkward this position
doesn't look that easy to assess because
there's a lot of tension on e4 on f5 on
d4 and d5 pawns aiming at each other and
they open at file if a car can get that
rook free to put pressure may be down in
the f2 square for instance that can be
good for him but it is risky
strategically to play move like f5
because some of the light squares in
your Kings side become more vulnerable
you know but Hikaru has to play four or
at least a spicy position right I mean
losing two Dingley Wren would be not
ideal but I think that I think that
every one of these guys came in with a
bit of a hey we got to go get them and
obviously Accardo choosing the most
aggressive possible option in this
position which is to open things up and
like you said the risk of being in a
must-win situation is you may be more
likely to lose but I think that's why he
Karl played this idea
and he's a very strong tactical player
of course um but strategically I just
always worry about it maybe it's totally
fine and Dingley Ren is just trying to
figure it out but III don't see the
exact move here at Danny because the
detention right that is what this
position revolves around these
detentions like each takes f5 for white
black takes the night under five you can
see a series of trains in f5 if you keep
taking like I just want to take it all
through I mean there was also taking on
d7 first as an option but what uh
Robert help me well you can't take on d7
actually right I know I've got sure
which one's better but if you you take
on d7 take with the bishop on d7 okay to
avoid the pin now for de de you can't
take with the knight on e5 because f2 is
hanging and you can't take with the rook
on e5 but then I'm guessing some kind of
Bishop c6 and yeah your Knights sort of
pin there's the queen of six by the way
in some weird position you know not
right away cuz at d7 but I was I was
looking at some weird development thing
if you could get really aggressive but
okay h3 what instead of instead of
Bishop c6 there's also Bishop takes h3 I
guess ah right okay there you go
on that note because the queen is
hanging and if you take here you take
and the knight is capture Balazs of the
variation and black is actually just
winning so so like you said it karo is a
isn't a great tactical player and he
feels maybe in a practical scenario
where he needs to get a win and it is a
rapid game that he needs to bring the
heat to Dingley Wren and he's probably
anticipating takes takes takes takes but
you'll see if it will result in a GG yo
did you look at you speaking fluent
twitch making the fans happy yeah okay
there's there's another matchup going on
let's not forget that they control their
own destiny as we back this thing up
Maxime vache the Grove in a very just
equal balance game you know they're
they're in a better position because a
draw for them still forces the us to
beat China which is which is going to be
tough so not that they don't want to be
twirled but they definitely don't want
to lose and so this is this is a matchup
that that will keep our eye on we also
have all your rows of Purusha taken on
Levon Aronian we'll check back on that
one in a second I'm just I'm spying all
the games here partner if you see
something you want to throw to just just
say the word I'm looking around as well
trying to figure out which game we
should stay on and I see him one results
in the books in India and Russia those
teams are eliminated so you know all
right question I saw and I didn't even
want to bring it up on the board but
yeah Sergei Kuryakin has already drawn
his game with Nutella Hari Krishna okay
we have to bring up the game between
dinara self cassava and Nana's leg means
a because unlike the previous round
Nana's leg means is in big
trouble right now and is Sava csoka
about to play spoiler and a lot of Team
USA it's a super final because I mean
Danny that game is looking really bad
for Nana I'm attempting to find it right
now I'm sorry there's a whole lot of
games going on and I did not have it
pulled up remind me of the username and
I'll just do it the old-fashioned way
it's a well dinara son of a cassava is
is this a long name so you're gonna have
trouble spelling that one what about
dogs means is its its Lu Li Li
underscore Ani and I cannot believe I'm
reading out usernames to you on a live
show but that's what happens when
there's so many games going on Ranger
things have happened and three seasons
seasons of it apparently have happened
and shout out to Winona Ryder really
turn in that career round
look at this position and I'm sorry okay
well yeah well what I'm looking at is
rook takes f6 because that is I love
sacrificing the exchange with my
favorite things to do in chess but 95 to
follow it up and the King is still in
the center for black I feel like it's a
very straightforward attack right if the
Queen comes with check you just move the
King and black has not solved any
problems and this was a B for ideas for
example Bishop e6 oh man b4 Queen Queen
CC I mean you could play that be sick I
don't even know if I want to write
because other moves are also good but
yes certainly a 96 looks great and you
can take a 8 and win d6 and probably be
doing just fine so she's pausing how did
we get here Robert you said Sudoku Silva
is gonna be doing Team USA a huge favor
if she slows down and beats not as
agnesi but but what happened to get such
a weird position we have a time mana of
Sicilian still all theory so far Bishop
to d6 one of the more tricky lines f4
Knight d4 Queen d4 on e5 ok now we're
already getting in a weird position
where black has to be super careful I
don't know the theory anymore and I'm
wondering if it's because it's not maybe
not the best line I don't know but I've
already like in white but maybe this is
theoretical and I'm overestimating my
chances because somehow I mean to me
that exchange sac is so natural where
I'm just taking on the 695 but as I look
on the screen here I can't see exactly
what the eval bar registers but what
seems like it's saying it's good for
white I think it's very good for white I
think that
uh this a five idea is often often a a
response in like a Scheveningen the
Sicilian Pollan structure if you can get
away with it and keep a piece on the e5
square but it often happens later when
when you've maybe got a pawn on d6
Bishop on e7 as soon as you get E 5 it
slows down the attack and you land with
a knight on e5 or something just I'm
kind of pointing out you know just sort
of in a general way that a five is a
positional strike back to this advance
but in this particular line again I will
have to check theory here
I guess because rook d1 was played
instead of the exchange sack so
apparently either either we got things
that are being missed or there's
something about this we don't know I
still think White's better but certainly
not as good as that exchange sac was
looking although I guess just the safe
and sound method is good too going after
d6 because if you ever bring your King
up to protect that pollen then I'm
certainly thinking about sacking my
exchange in f6 so I think that black is
just going to be worse and suffering
this one speaking of safe and sound
though we got to back up and take a look
at you young G's game versus Grandmaster
Wesley so because it's one of those
positions that looks very safe and sound
for white it's close to equal of course
but it also just uh it already feels
like a tube result position for you
young yi in this rule of has berlin a
structure that can also occur out of an
exchange french and anna Petroff in a
lot of ways but you young Yi backing on
camera struggling to relay the message
from Naboo that that the Republic is
approaching well it does seem like it's
just an even game it's a symmetrical
pawn structure White's Knight is doing
well on c5 and in fact sometimes you
want black to play b6 to try to kick it
because that allows me to put eight
takes b6 and make my rook on a1 look
more useful and weakens the light
squares on the Queen side so whether or
not to play b6 for black is a tough
question but oh I guess white answers
with like a six self
he plays a six cuz he wants to once they
said I want to be a long-term target but
this is this is interesting the point is
that if you take everybody the queen is
overworked she has to guard f5 and the
b-pawn at the same time so taking would
be a huge blunder as you can see but but
black doesn't have to take
so what would you do is remove your
night away or something um yeah it's
hard because you're threatening to take
on d6 and I I don't have a squirtle move
my knight beside z4 but maybe I can
actually now that you suggested what a
move and what a constant with a 697 did
not come to my mind at all and it may be
because it wasn't the best I I don't I
mean it's super super tricky right but
he by the way 94 played by so quickly
responded to with rookie one where the
threat is f3 from you young AE the idea
is the trade here would weaken c7 and
this is being played so fast by you
young e there's no way this position has
been known by prep but I feel like
something about this concept deals
almost alpha zero ish in terms of how
they I don't know I mean I just feel
like he feels confident that he can make
this work or he wouldn't have gone for
it yeah um and you know he can't expand
on the kingside next with some kind of
g4 app or f3 g4 into any order because
you can't take on g4 I don't think but
the point is that maybe he's looking to
expand up both sides of the bore and say
hey I just have a spacial edge here and
though it's a symmetrical pawn structure
my knight on b7 and at some moment it
might get out of there and be tricky for
you to deal with we got to go back to
Fabiano car walnuts game because the
eagle has landed
Bishop takes h7 is on the board so
whether it was missed before or not I
don't think we were wrong maybe there
was even more to the blunt to the
struggles for black here than we
realized again if you're just tuning in
everybody the drama was real when Bishop
d7 was played here from Wang Hao and you
could see like wait a second we were
screaming for this Bobby doesn't play it
but still manages to kind of manufacture
the attack over here bringing pieces
over and once the Queen lands on f4 the
threat has been renewed because after
Bishop d7 takes captures would be losing
on the spot to queen h5 where you can't
defend mate and Knight f7 with a fork so
Bishop takes h7 met by King h8
you
and Bobby's Bobby's Bobby's looking
fantastic Bobby yes that oh that is
right fool me once shame on you fool me
twice shame on me
and he wasn't gonna be full of the
second time he took on aged seven and
right here he's up a pawn and the only
hope that I would say black really has
is if the Queen's get traded and you're
only down that H pawn in an endgame you
have some chance survive but look what
Fabien is doing he's just pressing
forward yeah you now as not only an
extra pawn but great attacking chances
and he's looking to score this point for
Team USA Wow
if so so we got to take stock now right
we're gonna we're gonna back up and do a
quick kind of just check in on every
board because this is what USA needed if
Fabiano is gonna is gonna win this game
let's go over to hit Caro and do me Ren
real quick we'll flash that board this
is this is gonna be a crazy one Baker
ooh looks to be holding his own right
now the the game between you and Jun and
Irina crush hasn't gotten a lot of
attention but that may end up proving
super critical because
whoa irena crush has a great position
here I mean you just like the the
central pawns and I've seen this in some
high-level games that I can't remember
who was playing but these sort of ideas
I felt there was a magnet or so game
like this if I'm remembering correctly
and yeah these kind of lines scare me
from the perspective of the black side
because I look at the strong center and
also the bishop on b2 if I can
eventually push my deep on that Bishop
has the scope of the board's longest
diagonal and so this could definitely go
Irina's way in the near future that said
black still has some chances here an
eventual h5 to h4 type of move you know
if you're ski and I go Knight to c4 and
I worried you didn't capture on b2 that
can change the nature of this game as
well so it's a dynamic position where
white surely is to be preferred but it's
not so clear-cut yeah it's yeah it's
weird so white obviously preferred
because of the the big center like you
said the space but but 95i means just
pointing out the obvious everyone the
default is pinned that's why the knight
is not hanging you you cannot take care
without losing the Queen and as Robert
said that means there there must be a
queen move right now it's just a
question of where Irena wants to put her
and then likely nice c4 with tempo
something something like I mean I want
to do things like Queen to b3 but I feel
like that's maybe just a little bit too
too much of a Danni move fantasizing
about checkmate over here maybe just sit
tight on the position okay nice c4 and
you just kind of sit tight Bishop a1 or
bishop c1
yeah the Pont a3 is totally irrelevant
to the actual position so this the
position looks good for white but Danny
I mean I take the draw our attention
away from this game but Fabiano Caruana
looks like he's just a mover to away
from Wow
okay we're heading back Fabiano putting
on a Petroff show right yeah this is a
statement right now one thing we didn't
talk about we highlighted this in other
potential feed a candidates upcoming
match ups at Fabiano and wang hao played
yet with uh with this particular color
setter they played obviously but as
Fabiano gotten white yet against one
hell I'm trying to wrap my brain I'm not
remembering but what I do know is that
Wang Hao just resigned so the game is
officially over this has been absolutely
crazy so did we just get some candidates
prep that Fabiana was willing to bust
out in order to help save team you ace
USA's chances cuz again just to give the
high-level review everybody these are
the two best most leading experts in the
petshop defense but Fabiano just flexed
on his approach here as white maybe
didn't even play the most
straightforward way but this tactic and
the attack was unstoppable and he is so
he may have just played the game of the
day goes absolutely bananas over here on
longhouse kingside and walkout resigns
in lieu of King to g8 just gonna be met
by just I guess there's take f6 and and
crush looks good two pawns it with an
attack yeah that's an easy one so not a
good one therefore wang hao boy china
still clearly the number one team in
this tournament but let's see how maybe
team Europe's doing because we have
given us a all the attention but you
know if they win it doesn't matter if
team europe ones true I just flashed the
board here between Dingley running a
corner more obviously lots of critical
stuff going on but I agree with your
call let's head over to Olly Reza
ferocious game with the Levon Aronian we
highlighted it as a key matchup
obviously especially if firoozeh can
play spoiler alert I don't know how you
play spoiler alert but you can play
spoiler spoiler alert you can be a
spoiler he's trying to trying to do what
he can but lavon's position looks looks
very solid yeah it's one of those
positions with the two bishops from why
and you're trying to plan both sides of
the board but as I know full well from
Washington karna Kimora's games and
being on the losing side of games
against him in blitz when you had these
nights and you just have a c4 square
under your control it's just you know
not allowing white to mobilize in the
queenside so that a for pawn is a
long-term weakness where black at some
point but life's like pawn a5 himself
and then play pawn b5 and create an
outside past pawn on the Queen side yeah
it's a really great point that it is
also long-term if you do it too early
then maybe you give you give White
weaknesses to target so it's it's a
patient game Bishop e6 maybe being
played to put the bishop on f7 White has
a small edge objectively I guess because
of the bishop hair and kind of the space
but I agree with you a lot of the
long-term factors say say that black is
a rock and this is going to be really
hard to break down and team Europe's
chances are not looking good because I
don't see a single game where I can
really claim an advantage for them and I
can see some tough position for NHANES
agnesi that board is really wearing
let's do it
well head over there that means he's
what's the hero in many ways in the last
round if you're just joining us she
defeated Irina crush but in in this
round and this round she's not looking
great right now and what a what a
storyline that would be China has not
lost the entire the entire event
Team USA already up one to nothing
because of a brilliancy here from
Fabiano Caruana Wow create a crazy stuff
and in this particular game white is
simply up a pawn right now so that d6
pawn did fall white is up upon blacks
King is in the center which in some ways
can be good because we're getting into
an endgame but it's a position where
white can play risk free chess and
essentially try to do what Nana did
Irina crush earlier today so it's the
roles have been reversed and now it's
not on the defensive it's not a lost
cause I would actually argue that you
know let's say you can think about
taking on g4 right now and taking on e5
and I I'm not positive about how this
one is going but I see this rook on d6
being active I don't know if I can get
away with rook takes g7 or if you've
makes you 6 to follow a member
gets trapped there so there's a lot more
I guess and immediately met the eye but
and maybe actually night 65 is a saving
grace for Nana they're actually this
Brooke is in trouble and g7 yeah unless
you can get away with like
just all in pressure right rook c7 night
Eve or or making your feet you had 95
has to be played because 94 is too slow
I wanted to come to d6 so rook c7 would
happen that by this but then you go here
and that way then you have this like
crazy idea of taking maybe and then
Knight f6 and you have myself King of
Fame your rook on g7 is a goner so I
mean there are tactics of course yeah
though it's feeling better for black now
that I'm actually analyzing instead of
attacking broader strokes
yeah the concrete details feel like SOG
needs he is maybe in a potential to hold
this obviously Sudoku Silva is thinking
trying to make sure that wait no no
sorry I'm not in the light position now
we've caught up Knight takes e5 as per
plate
okay and if that means you can hold this
I mean a team Europe still looks like
they need to win their match because
they draw and USA wins then USA has more
board points so it's sad for Team Europe
that the onus is still on them to score
match victory right yeah draw and match
assuming that that USA might be able to
hold and the advantage of a victory so
early from a guy like Fabiano Robert
let's talk about that because that sets
the tone for your match I mean you
basically just sent the memo to the team
just draw your game and we win the match
right I mean Fabiano's win this early is
a is a it's more than just a victory
right it's the fact that it it actually
helps the strategy because everybody
else is now playing for two results
exactly and I mean I don't even know
where our tension should be because I'm
looking from game to game my car is game
I'm looking wesley versu yangjia it's
hard because we have to look at so many
games at once because every single point
is critical here yeah well we we are
likely about to be joined by a super
special guest so we're gonna stay right
here and try to figure out the depth of
this game before we move on so if so do
cassava has a way to keep pushing do you
think it's with rook takes g7 or do you
think she needs to swallow swallow the
pride and say you know I just lost the
pawn back let me just forget it
centralized and you know be a little bit
better but no longer really playing for
a big advantage if I can extricate my
rook then rook takes g7 is a good move
but to my eyes in immediately I don't
see how that rook gets out but is there
some kind of rook p6 move just plan to
give up the exchange and take on b7
that's also an idea that comes in mind
but I yeah well I don't even even King
f8 they're just trapping the Brooklyn
yeah no I think it had to be the line I
was looking at earlier with rook f6 and
then and then we'll see if she has
something on rook c7 but we'll have to
come back to that because right now
we're gonna see what the man of the hour
has has to say about this game Fabiano
first of all just we're gonna kind of
break rules here and back up a little
bit to show a game that's already done
instead of the live games because you
you uh you just set the tone I mean I
think more than just the match the the
victory you just got you basically gave
the team a chance to now play for two
results right even if they draw every
game from here Team USA might do the
improbable so how you feeling right now
after that big win yeah and this was
incredibly lucky break it's not really
since it happened so quickly it really I
think takes the pressure off my
teammates and looking at the games I
think that we're doing we're in
excellent shape because he card oh I
think it's completely fine
I think Wesley is at least completely
fine and Irina is probably better
[Music]
because which is a big one as well I
mean I can't imagine that that white
risks anything here I mean I definitely
has chances for an advantage the only
risk is that of course if she gets too
ambitious it could get done which they
could turn around but since she knows
that our team is all then I don't think
she'll she'll do anything too risky plan
for a win and the other boys are quite
state as well so this is amazing any one
of us can ask questions here because you
you had us on the edge of our seat in
this position already and I have to ask
was this you said it you got incredibly
lucky is that because did wang hao just
fall into some prep that you've had here
I mean how early did you know that this
was just a great position for white no I
well the thing is I I feel a little bit
silly because I have played this against
me and the candidates this line and so I
know this line pretty well because
because I played against Magnus in the
World Championship match it was our prep
for the match and so there's a lot of
like old ideas from 2018 that I have and
before the game I had to choose one of
them and all the ideas are sort of they
don't like give white an advantage but
they're all kind of tricky and this
particular one I with Bhishma for is
it's very easy not that to miss an
analysis because the computer just
doesn't show it and the reason is
because black is probably better after
this tough work but it is very
complicated and and he I think went
wrong immediately with Bishop g4 he had
to play see foreign key play Bishop back
AHA so there you go you're answering it
so and you know it's funny and not to
toot our own but we we had a feeling cuz
when you played Bishop before he paused
and took a couple minutes right so
something kind of smelled fishy that at
least he wasn't expecting that move
order and you just revealed that we were
right because because it's not good for
you right and apparently but apparently
he didn't know the idea and so as soon
as he played Bishop g4 were you uh were
you starting to get a little bit excited
here and and by the way why didn't you
take h7 right away will you teach us
this because we thought it we thought it
was good um no I just
this just seems to win Elizabeth yeah
that's what we were looking at and we
thought that you were just considering
making sure triple checking and then you
played c4 which gives you a still a
great position yeah you should have seen
Wong House reaction yeah through himself
back in the chair took a swig and was
like yeah I saw some life burning a
great attack but let's let's get your
opinion on the live game here because it
just got crazy between dingo renting a
car Nakamura after the move rook takes
h6 well Queen if I've already responded
to I guess okay just to point out the
obvious everybody taking is the reason
why rotation has played that would be a
problem but actually she said Bobbie hey
car was fine if Queen of five we might
get an obstacle Bishop ending here no
but this is this is not a final game I
mean hundred eight six I guess one other
explanation is there because it looks
fine just before like what was this
movie for he played King g8 on the check
so we're gonna back up until you see
something maybe eight wasn't late April
maybe was gonna say 411 26 yeah he
probably should have played something
like Ruka I don't but they thought is
also hanging so yeah maybe there were
some some issues like whites Queen and
Bishop are teaming up faster than blacks
you know Bishop on c6 on g2 so White has
a little bit more sustained pressure but
Danny as we go to the live position and
we go forward here then we see that
black is trade in Queens
so probably how do you assess blacks
chances to hold a pawn down rook and
Bishop Obamas of color ending I think
this particular one is really not fun
for black okay let's say he takes it
takes on a core of g6 or if someone will
get something like this
and then White has to
try to dance have it - maybe but maybe
you can't really hold this construction
so easily
I guess I will storm it like h4 or
something but the King h7
[Music]
and then age 5 over g5 something like
that and like we'll probably try to stir
this real quick Bishop b4 but I would
say it's like it's 50/50 got it yeah
that makes sense and I mean Bobby your
team's results sort of becomes
irrelevant if Team Europe is able to win
so are there any games in that matchup
that you sort of have your eyes on or
worried about in particular or happy
about in favor of the team from the rest
of the world well last I saw some of the
Kosovo was was a home for absolutely
nothing no wait what yeah it it turned
around right here Bishop g4 was played
and and the trade with e5 it was very
spicy but apparently the computers think
white could have got away with this so
do cassava does does not go for that and
now it looks like Zug Nietzsche is is
back in the game
yeah I guess she'll play tonight 684 and
just black control a castle I mean I
guess why it's still better but it's not
so longer what it was before are there
are some ways that may be why can't
prevent black and gozman instead of
night takes a foreplay like Knight d5
because then I have 97 check ideas if
you try to castle so I mean I agree with
you that it seems like black has made a
better situation of one that looked very
tough but maybe you're not totally out
of the woods yet no this is tricky I
mean I would think that black should
play 95-year because they were and I
don't just I just don't see that room
and then try to reinforce it with f6
this looks pretty solid of course there
is stuff like Murphy 7 black still can't
castle and I can't take 1 C 2 because
we're pH so so it actually doesn't it
doesn't look too Pleasant either so with
this game then I mean I guess okay
anything can happen is as we know
blunders blunders happen but with that
game where you thought does that means
you would be a big favor right that kind
of puts you in a position where you
start thinking maybe maybe team world
can draw this match right the game
between Aronian and Purusha seems ok for
all the reza maxime doesn't really have
an edge at all as white against her job
of so so what are you what are you
thinking right now no it's a good
situation I think that ali reza has
probably a more comfortable position
I mean blacks King is a little bit
unsafe the visual of g5 is really strong
and I don't see is completely no post I
don't see how a black board organizes
pieces on the other hand they still
pretty solid for one and this is this is
a funny one with this a six-night b7
idea of the it kind of had a a kind of
shock to us what do you think of this
idea III said and probably probably
crazy crazy lead that maybe it's an idea
he's prepped not of course the exact
position but maybe he's thinking ok this
is an idea you can make work because it
seemed so odd to do this to put your
knight on b7 when you didn't have to but
what do you think about maybe he just
thinks this is just fine for white and
this match is not to rolling for them
yeah I mean it's actually completely
irrelevant absolutely they could have
some fun and also he's had a very good
event so far so he's probably kind of
confident and feels he might get away
with something like this it doesn't look
clear to me I don't because black will
have to make a like let's say black ice
queen d son and white takes I would
think that black will take with the a
pond but this doesn't last poem so
there's probably black doesn't want to
do this right I mean you can thinking
with the seafoam levels you know light
on my LD six
and what is only one can be better for
26 so so I don't know what I mean he can
also take on v7 and I wasted him right
now
you know take sake and CB looks I mean I
mean okay Queen b6 is very safe but it's
going to be a draw most likely and well
there's also route C 7 to 1 instead of
Queen e6 to watch out for
I don't know that's too concerning for
black because you can just click Queen
b8 I have not seen that way why don't
you have enough for a draw well but
black is also ok but why I mean if black
doesn't want to allow XC 7 and all this
stuff you just like Queen takes me six
it's completely safe yeah well Bobby I
mean I hate to divert our attention
really cook but I do have one game that
we haven't given enough attention to and
I think your input would extremely
valuable cuz it's not so clear to me
in Jung Christophe Duda where's boss mi
me and over in the Europe versus rust
the world match what do you make of this
position because no pawns have been
traded and White has two knights against
the two bishops I don't like blacks
position very much I would like him more
he'd be if he could have gotten
organized in time if you get it let's
say I was Queen on d8 and get c5 Bishop
g7 and and something where but now it
feels like White will get c5 in the pond
e4 will be very weak I think that's why
it's plan like next move
you know when black can't play c5
himself because there's just there's a
PC to be king so yeah that's that's huge
c5 is collective should be six comes to
mind here well then why can't the Queen
B - and I'm threatening to one directly
so you think this is team Europe sort of
chance to punch through a victory
because the match hasn't been looking
very good for them yeah I think this is
a good chance to win
yeah I think I want is pressure here but
they're both kind of a long time so it
could get random is even if you win this
pawn on d4 black does have doesn't will
always have some time to play physically
bishops yeah well Fabi it's been amazing
to have you with us again you set the
tone here with a huge magic
if you're one of the 25,000 plus with us
you're just tuning in Fabiano Caruana
defeats wang hao in a in a fantastic
game that finished quickly but before we
let you go do us one last favor and just
take a look at this game with Dingley
running Hikaru obviously ding pushing
but if you were to set up some sort of
defensive setup like give us the high
level I would want my bishop here my
rook here how does black potentially try
to hold this end game you think well
this was particularly easy because if
I've got my bishop on c4 would be fun I
think black is already better okay yeah
8 2 is a problem I guess and this is
what he's gonna try to get by playing I
think this would be 7 next move and then
deceases right he's going to just start
some counter play the few questions are
like if I can get away with rotate 5 but
I assumed level generated counter play
against g2 more time with rookie 7 right
I think it's actually we're gonna fight
with you something is his only move
otherwise you have no way to actually
get right into White's position so
that's one critical line because white
does that you know moves here in b5 for
example but b5 I think doesn't shouldn't
worry about because at least TSP 6 at
the very least be six and rotate three
Bishop b5 right nice big b5 and just
probably should thank me 5 sorry I'm
have a little trouble here
Harun go ahead this is really equal
awesome because what's puzzling not
broken his work is bad I don't know I
see 4 is also a logical move instead of
working 5
I don't think that's c4 very much rule
but it allows 157 so maybe this is a bad
move I don't know if white wants to do
that okay well you helped I guess point
out the a to pawn here and maybe some of
the critical lines we might see at this
okay obviously a lot still ahead who
knew you would be done so quickly right
now you get to go have some rest and
watch watch your teammates maybe maybe
do what people thought was improbable
here and then be China and get your way
into the super final so either way Fabi
congratulations on a great event here
whether you make it to tomorrow or not
and thank you for being so awesome with
all these all these times you've joined
us thanks for having me see if back over
here to the hikaru cam the Dingley run
cam Aviano the may be one of the
highlights of the event so far as far as
the show goes that he's joined us so
much and given his thoughts you know
it's been it's been awesome to have him
in most of these rounds and he's been
doing so well that we have the pleasure
of having joined the broadcast and I
mean some of these games are just like
I'm looking at the NHANES like needs a
game once more because I'm throwing
ourselves from match to match because
these are the two matches that dictate
who makes to the super final and not as
I need his king is out on g6 and in her
game yeah but I think she's escaping
here
I think she's doing okay but but if
we're predicting it's still a position
that why probably won't lose then I'm
actually wondering what's gonna happen
in the Le Reza Purusha Levon Aronian
game cuz that game looks like firoozeh
is breaking through so sorry to switch
gears again but I think that game may
end up becoming the critical one because
Olli Reza has opened the H file this
looks this looking very dangerous for
love and LaVon had a shaky game earlier
today against Fabiano where I firstly
loved his position in venom Stan he was
down in exchange but right now you're
right that that rook on h6 is hitting
the pond on g6 and dark square is
vulnerable around the black king so if I
can get that configuration I want Bishop
to have six or you know slimy other rook
to h1 incomes are up to h8 so actually I
mean what is black Jew here
Knight f7 hangs the g6 pawn which is
kind of frustrating but then drive King
h7
maybe that's the key idea is this is
this is kind of it's kind of a problem
actually you could actually check and
then pin which is funny
yeah wait actually how do you respond to
this maybe that's maybe that's what you
have to do I don't know yeah looks looks
good for black so Knight of seven there
has to be a move because there's no way
I'll erase oh just like walked into a
knife fork without a solution available
to himself so
I don't know do you take on Jesus in the
e6 excuse me and then Oh baby baby yeah
that's a good idea and then you can
bring the other Roy page1 yeah you also
then Bishop c1 Bishop d3 kind of stuff
too and that's nice kick the night out
the main point of that everybody is it
opens the d3 square well I want to go
Bishop f5 next that's my plan
see one wow what an interesting position
of an interesting moment right here
Brooke age six played and Levon is on
the clock but speaking of the clock I
think that's the thing you're nervous
about if you're firoozeh under five
minutes though you know he's for someone
who's known as such a fast player he's
managed his time well I think as far as
you know slowing down he's been willing
to get low on the clock to make sure he
converts a good position he used this
time well in the game was Sergey
Karjakin in the previous round and I
know we didn't fall in line but I was
watching it closely and he yeah he was
using his time well and and so if that
pays off with a great position that it's
worth it
yes and LaVon is bouncing yeah that's
been his his reaction of choice thus far
but it is a critical moment here I think
he will spend more time because it's
it's not an easy choice whether to play
Knight of seven or maybe I don't know
what other moves are really possible
here but the king f7 doesn't look right
either so I think we're in for a bit of
a thing from LaVon okay well while he
thinks we have a result in the books
that we have to shoot over to Maxine by
Sheila Groff has drawn his game versus
Taymor of her job off so that's that's
one result in the books that I guess
kind of helps Team USA cuz at least they
know for sure that can't be a victory
because now that they might be China a
drawn match for Europe means the USA
leapfrogs them although or neck seam
wasn't the worst sign of the draw
throughout the game so I guess you know
in that hint in that sense you're like
oh gosh could team y'all have done a
little more but you're right it does
bring that match little more clarity
look at this position yeah let's go over
to this young Christopher do two versus
the good doctor because you're right
it's the one that we haven't given
nearly enough attention to especially
because it might be team Europe's best
hope at a W here with Jake ad play
Dwight and I kind of had that game of
the corner of my life throughout I
needed Fabiano's input because they're
all eight pawns for both sides still
remaining and you don't see that very
often and Bishop versus two knights you
tend to like that but with so many pawns
on the board those bishops aren't
exactly doing so much and after c5 the
d4 pawn is in some trouble I don't think
was going to take it just yet because
then you're walking into a pin on the g7
diet from the Michelin g7 to the Queen
on b2 so you have to be careful about
that but black also need to move right
here right now and I'm not seeing an
easy one
yeah I'm uh I'm not either I mean you'd
like to just kind of stare down and not
do anything because like you said taking
d4 is a little poisoned but you can't
just rely on that because you don't have
enough to win the piece and so white
white can eventually take it do even
something like take d6 play e5 to block
the bishop and use one appalling
that's true you can't let it sit there
for too long but I also think that if
you make some kind of committal this is
like a 5 for instance comes to mind for
black but that's a typical idea but when
the beep 7 pawn is so weak and if I was
rook to e8 which I think is a totally
fine move but maybe I'll just move my
Queen out of the way from the diagonal I
think a queen move threatens the pawn on
d4 and I'm happy if you ever played D
take c5 because after B takes d5 for
white that b7 pawn becomes a true target
yes so almost like it's one of those
weird positions like when someone has an
isolated pawn but the best thing to do
is actually not to take it but to just
continue to build your stronghold around
it sort of comparable here white white
doesn't really want to take you know and
then give black the the potential
compensation it wants to sit on the
advantage the bishops as you said don't
have a lot of scope with so many pawns
on the board but then on that note how
do you make a breakthrough how do you
how do you force black to blink first
right because as you said just have
pointed out visually again this is this
is really not what you ever want so what
does why do that if not take the d4 pawn
here maybe Queen d2 just get my Queen
off the diagonal because then am
threatening the pawn okay okay and I'm
hoping you take me on c5 but you'd love
that but I won't do that no soup for you
okay there's not really anything clear
for black to do instead yeah
and this we've actually threatens other
things if you really end up want to
force it like not just Knight takes d4
but Queen f4 I mean you wouldn't you're
not trying to switch to the to the King
side necessarily just pointing out that
White has ways to kind of poke and in
black doesn't have great ways to improve
the pieces but you know who doesn't
great ways to prove the pieces Alireza
for rougeau because if we go over back
to that game his attack has been heating
up and look at the rook on g1
threatening a knight at five type of
checker and that h5 type of check wow
everything is going right with whites
pieces and black has not found a way to
defend that King wow what a game here
firoozeh wins again it's been the board
twos that seemed cursed for Team Europe
in this last round if you're just tuning
tuning in
Fabiano car 101 a fantastic game against
wang hao that he revealed was basically
prep is as old as his World Championship
match versus Magnus Carlsen in 2018 and
kind of played a line that he knows is a
little suspect but maybe a good choice
for rapid and it paid off
Fabiano destroys wang hao on for two and
oli Rosa Fallujah might be beating the
the Europe board two right now and he
would be the hero for the American team
it sounds we playing for the world team
right but hero they asked for
necessarily not on their team but the
one they're getting this yeah
interesting I mean just look at this
position and where does black even move
here there's so many threats revolving
around this g6 pawn the king being on g7
and maybe he just run away with King f8
but can I just steal your pawn and ask
questions later you'd like that right I
mean the threat of 9 h5 is a real
problem so
I mean just to point out again
everywhere like if you try to defend the
G pawn instead here comes the night to
h5 and I don't know where the Kings
gonna go
maybe tries to run out then you've made
that for regard right oh I was gonna
point out you don't have to move the
knight because it's pinned but you're
right your move is very forcing so just
do it and go win the poetry so yeah this
is rook g1 the the the shuffle right the
truffle shuffle
and it's something that's actually easy
to miss because your work on h1 looks so
good double then an open file but
there's a key on g7 and now you're
creating problems on two different files
and he's just going right after that
King I really don't see a mover King f8
it feels like the move that's necessary
just so you don't immediately lose the
game because I see so many lines looking
like it results in immediate defeat but
but the G Paul is falling like you said
yeah it's Wow it's just such an
unpleasant position like you said rook
you've won easy to miss the truffle
shuffle almost as easy to miss as an 80s
cult classic there we go
USA is I mean I'm looking at Wesley
shows game now because everything's
going right for Team USA let's do it
back out of that game
and you saw that eval bar just plummet
and go in blacks favor
look at that king on f2 versus the king
on g7 one of those two Kings is safe and
I promise you it's not White's
first person to mention the the chunk
Goonies reference in the twitch chat
send me a message on Twitter you get
yourself a diamond membership for that
subtle pop culture I was feeding you get
the you get the hidden reward all right
yeah this is fantastic from Wesley I
mean at least as Fabiano said he he's
not gonna lose this as black right okay
we can always be speaking too soon
blunders happen but but black is black
is maybe better and certainly not gonna
lose this position but for sure as for
choice C by the way Wes was no declined
a draw I can see it the draw was offered
which is already huge right because he
knows he only needs a draw really but if
he gets a win that would be that would
be clinching it regardless of what
happens in Caruana I'm sorry in Nakamura
and crushers game well I wouldn't say a
draws that necessarily enough because if
he draws then Team USA makes a draw
overall and Team Europe draws than USA's
out so I would say wants to win the
match so I would never accept the draw
here with the dominant position yep
especially as I look to hit cars game a
little nervously as being the rent still
remains a bit better than that one and
you know I've know what's gonna happen
between Jew and Jun across just because
it's positioned without any sort of
clarity yeah crazy stuff Bishop d3 now
played by you yogi again the reason is
that the d4 pole was hanging so you're
kind of cutting off the queen of rooks
communication on the poland but but
black has to be just doing good here how
do you how do you make progress do you
keep bringing more forces b5 b4 and kind
of disrupt the blockade or is there
something more concrete I want to play
Queen a1 well then I figure White's
gonna push the B pawn and then my Queen
has to leave the first ring which is
pretty annoying so yeah yes
still doing fine there but again if you
want to win right that's not the
approach he'd he also has a time
advantage Wesley so so now's the time to
put pressure on white I kind of like b5
I don't know if it's a good move it
would just be the move I would play as a
human to say let me just disrupt this
Queen whose key to guarding everything
in white structure right oh yeah and one
thing to keep an eye on perhaps Dan Ian
and maybe I'm just getting crazier if
the Queen moves away from a four perhaps
it's some moment when some Senate rooks
sacrifice an f72 yeah say you don't have
any defenders I'll get a draw by a bunch
of checks and it seems far-fetched but
sometimes those things happen yeah you
got to keep an eye on it and the engine
reveals that if you miss it it's a it's
a computer move that they never miss and
human beings aren't always ready to give
up their works with check but but you
got to keep an eye on that Oh Danny we
gotta go to ding Li Ren versus Hikaru
Nakamura this is exactly why Wesley
didn't take a draw because look at this
game here and Dinkley run is winning how
did he break through on the queenside
what technique here amazing he's up to
pawns now compared to the one Accardo
has gotten the rooks off the board but
the problem is you can't really guard
the H pawn and the threat here's what's
gonna happen everybody the White King
will come to b6 and if the bishop is
sitting on c6 then a six wins in those
positions because you can't take the
bishop hangs if it's on a six you drive
the C pawn but either way even if the
bishop isn't hanging all you have to do
is trade and I don't think you could
hold both these pawns right and they're
too far it's okay grade point a note and
I say this all the time
h8 square dark square bishop and the
reason why that can be so important here
is because at best white is gonna have
to trade off both of the queenside pawns
for that light square bishop that you're
gonna try to press for a win over there
and then you still have a winning pawn -
by the way results coming in rapid fire
I just took a breath and sat back on cam
we got a show we can stay here with
Nakamura and Dingley rent but firoozeh
has just defeated Levon Aronian and as
we said he may be the hero for Team USA
if somehow they they hold on but like we
said now Nakamura in trouble but we also
have a draw between humans Yoon and
Irina crush so maybe assessing her
teammates positions she thinks even if
Hikaru does it hold here maybe she likes
Wesley so
chances that much and oh my gosh look at
the Weslie cell game he's on the grind
here so Hikaru flustered again were as
he should be but let's let's go over to
this game here the you young a game with
Wesley so because you young E's first
loss of the event may come at the worst
time possible for fur for Team Europe
yes and you look at this position Duke
we look at that move
you know rook h1 I was saying earlier
that would that rook on d1 I wouldn't
wanted to play Queen a1 but after b3 the
Queen didn't have any more squares to
work with in the first rank so what does
Wesley do he gives his Queen more
squares of plain Brook each one attacks
the pawn h2 in the meantime and now
Queen e1 comes in and there's the G 1
square and more to work with so really
nice technique there by Wesley so
finding the way forward that you know
you weren't coming up with and now not
only is there Queen c1 sometimes there's
just you know after 23 there's Queen to
d6 opportunities as well oh wow that's a
retreating move you always say yourself
are hard to find so look at you that's
nice and again yes Queen e1 never
happened everyone but that's because of
the threat that robber pointed out so b3
was forced and this little game of
tickle is just all about spying this
first rank that you young you can not
allow Wow Wesley is leaning in and and
this you know Fabiano set the tone with
the win but this might be the the
victory of the mat just cuz you young G
has not lost yet I mean if Wesley does
this does the unthinkable beating the
player of the tournament with the black
pieces Team USA is gonna go wild and
it's not see easy yet because Queen a1
what you young eh iannuzo King to g3
he's gonna run his keen away and so you
actually don't have a check on my King
and well with that rook on c7 pinning
the pawn f7 there's actually opportunity
still for white to have some counter
threats and escape this one so you know
there's a knight h5 check at some moment
but I guess you young he's trying to
claim that my King goes the h-file and
survives for the time being yeah it's
like where's where's the mate where's
the beef so crazy
Queen a1 has been played and indeed you
called it the King puts on his running
shoes here we go
well this is really some some crazy
stuff another game we have to go to you
real quick we have to get we have to
back up here I'm sorry every game is
crazy but the young Christopher Duda
game with doctor the good doctor burse
Emma Mina but what is going on here this
is Duda is about to convert
but it's crazy the exchange sack Wow I
mean Basim Amin has had some great
exchange sacks in this event including
his five-minute car wanna coming up with
unique approaches and it looks like it
should just be good for white after rook
a 8 here pinning that Bishop on c8
because you take on e2 I take on c8 and
I will gobble up this past ponent you
have after rook to e1 at the end of this
variation but they're still chances to
hold as we heard next seen by Sheila
Groff say in our interview last round
when you have a bishop and those two
King side pawns against a rug and white
suit King side pollen so just use the H
and G pawns go ahead with a bishop
versus rook there are many ways to make
a draw there but with two rooks on the
board that's not going to be easy
Wow uh this is a wild one
the the I don't know what to say but the
good doctor doing what he can to hold it
speaking of the good doctor remind you
you can now download the dr. wolf app on
Android by the way while we have your
attention and that wasn't the the most
forced promo of all time then then you
are wrong all right here we go back to
the games all right
the hikaru by the way kind of slowing
down the pace a little bit I mean I
think partly from a practical point of
view he's trying to make sure that um
but he keeps the game going as long as
he can maybe to maybe to confuse Europe
to confuse everyone right by the way so
do cassava and Zog knees II have drawn
their game just to quickly flash that so
the the scoreboard as it reads is is is
accurate I think right now world the
world is leading Team Europe but again
maybe young Christopher due to changes
that with the W here is white I guess we
got to go back to the Wesley so game now
whoa the King has gone backwards
something bad happened for you young G
we're about to see a victory for so Dan
that King is just being hunted and Queen
d2 is in my rookie one check and
everything falls III there's Knight a
fortune yeah I was gonna show it the
night is coming to f4 King and ice I
don't know like this problem we know one
Queen e5 is checkmate my tights better
my twins the Queen okay okay alright
awesome awesome stuff okay well but how
so how did Wesley handle this Robert
give us give us the technical insight
your rookie one was the key move he
didn't go after the king he caused
confusion what a move to guard east six
right guard six and also even even free
up more squares so that we have the
first ring guess which one he chose but
he mattered most he chose me we all make
mistakes Danny okay did show everybody
Robert was correct matin too was on the
board Queen a one Queen a5 but you know
what Wesley shows where his heart is
with his family as his adopted kid and
I'm happy to call him a proud papa
guess who's happy about Team USA winning
captain John Donaldson
wowsers yep and so Hikaru's result is
irrelevant because trying to say has
already won the match yeah we show the
game he's doing his best to hold and
fight mightily he is so what we'll keep
an eye on it but again it's irrelevant
Team USA has just done the unthinkable
and defeated China in the last week they
have qualified to punch their ticket
which is official it's official oh my
gosh this match doesn't matter it
doesn't matter anymore because the rest
of world are it is two points which
means the best that Europe can do is tie
the match but because US eight was tied
in board points before and now they
clearly have more board points in this
round then the Team Europe does the USA
is going through two super final Sunday
oh my gosh well and you asked it earlier
it was just totally hypothetical the
time like who would you rather face if
you were China USA or Europe I guess it
doesn't matter they're gonna face USA
whether they like it or not and you
might say that maybe that's the easier
team or something people who thinking
crazily that China would do that on
purpose I don't think so you don't you
don't allow momentum to be handed to
anybody to face you because Team USA
just defeated the the top performer and
you young Yi Wesley so apparently was
the key and and they are gonna be riding
high into the super finals so this is
this could be a crazy day of drama
tomorrow and well I mean
acara Nakamura might not even lose and
that would be amazing at this point if
he saw how can survive this end game
because it does give him increased
confidence when he gets into the super
final because you don't want to go into
that on a loss especially when you have
a rematch against the same opponent yes
let's go over there and see acardo's
game with Dingley red again Jonker still
probably converts this but did did
Hikaru get the blockade he needed now
you highlighted the key which is if this
pawn can somehow make the bishop give it
up then you're always winning right
you've got the right color bishop for
the for the corner but but actually
that's notice that's it well that's
gonna be the plan right how does the
King come over here and not let the
black King attack the C pawn because if
you if you could just magically put the
white King on g6
now it's just an easy win for white you
just you just push the pullet right so
you can try to get your king over the to
the king side and then place c7 to put
your pawn and protected square but the
problem is and you start with c7 that's
a good move because now the king is
split right if the King goes to c8 the
white king goes to e7 you just push the
pawn you had to go King yeah that's
gonna be a you can see hit karo in fact
right there resigns a tough tough loss
but unfortunately for Team Europe it
doesn't matter Team USA is is dancing on
Sunday and we go back to the final game
remaining in that Europe versus world
match and what what about what a crazy
turn around this was and Yan Krishna
Duda I mean Denny we've been talking
about board three for Team Europe that
is the boy they've been struggling on
trying to figure out who to play between
a nice giri and yonkers Abdullah and
Yonkers have Duda coming up huge in this
game yeah it looks like he is going to
convert this but unfortunately it's too
little for Team Europe as Levon Aronian
loses to a red-hot all the grace of
Perugia who had two excellent games
beating Sergey Karjakin and Levon
Aronian the final day so I know his team
was out of it but you got a tip your cap
off to all the Rays of Perugia the
superstar not just a tomorrow but of
today yeah honestly again we kept saying
it he just he kind of won the match for
Team USA with this great game over Levon
Aronian as you just saw it was showing
that there is one game still going on in
this final 10th round if you want to
head over to chess comms live server or
just gonna go chess comm slash ONC games
it'll pull up the only game remaining
but we're not even going to talk too
much about it again all due respect to
help you can arrow and I'll go Gary Gary
abut the games that mattered are in the
books it started right here five in a
car wanna sets the tone with a shocking
swift victory over Wang Hao and then the
board to fortunes continued for USA cuz
Olly Reza firoozeh on a roll defeats
Levon Aronian the board one started to
swing team China's way / team Europe's
way is Dingley ran slowly outplayed
Hikaru but it was this game here between
Wesley so and you young a that I think
is the huge shocker because you
has been the absolute rock of the event
he goes for this plan of a six and night
b7 that as Fabiano said maybe he was
kind of having fun there but it
backfired because so unwound and
eventually converted on the biggest win
of the day winning his black over you
young he was not what we expected but
again I mean Team Europe Team Europe had
their own fate in their own hands right
I mean they LaVon LaVon lost $2 of
parousia right Zack needs a-- couldn't
get it done against against tyloo
cassava where she did win last night
over irina crush so sorry Robert from
rambling I'm just I'm just shocked by
the whole thing I had no idea where you
were going with all that I was waiting
for you to ask me I was giving a summary
I guess I didn't know what else to say
about the craziness that just happened
well you have to be proud of Wesley so
and of the US team because they lost a
really heartbreaking match earlier -
yeah the European squad and all of a
sudden you know Maxime was himself
feeling down about his game against
Hikaru where he's like I should have won
that game and actually in the end that
kind of board point really matters right
because if Maxie wins that game I guess
akaru that you know changes what happens
going into this round because then USA
needs to figure out okay if we win the
match and Europe draws how many points
that we need as a team and that changes
everything so actually that half your
own earlier today then Maxine was sure
the grab didn't get against Karan
Nakamura is maybe the difference well
it's a lot of course of second-guessing
things and what it coulda shouldas right
obviously Team Europe heartbroken right
now and we love those guys and garry
kasparov as the captain did everything
he could to uh to put them put the
lineup forward that would get the job
done but unfortunately Team USA shocks
the world maybe beats China in the last
round and no game was bigger than the
one right now we're gonna talk about
with grandmaster Wesley so joining us
Wesley I'm so proud of you dad yeah so
friendly well you said Gary did
everything he could right but he
actually didn't it what way because he
didn't play that's you know captains are
symbolic in many ways the players are
getting the job done and you certainly
did
Wesley what a crazy yeah crazy game well
although Wesley I'm sorry I know we're
gonna congratulate in a second but are
you a little disappointed you missed a
fourth segment at the end there yeah I
didn't see it until now I just saw it so
Wesley
funny story funny story I called for
rookie three and Robert called for Queen
a1 and guess which one you chose you
chose family no you chose rookie three
yeah that's great the Queen anyone but
like yeah I was I thought this when he
played King in Susa just kind of went
for it right well Leslie take us through
this game we had Fabiano join us earlier
because obviously he won his game very
quickly and so I'm just speeding through
what seemed like kind of just you know
standard standard stuff here for a
Berlin but will they actually played
this in Y can say against bloody flub
copper live okay I think he played like
night Deepti year or something like 93
in this position instead of a six yeah
or something similar like that Wow
really know instead of Queen III if you
go back he took on g5 instead takes on
g5 index decides got in then he he
played night of streak windy then windy
one and the difference is that my queen
has lost two Tempe going back to G
fights and in fact to d8 okay and why
it's a bit better okay so so when he
didn't do that
excuse me sorry were bouncing around
here all backup so when he instead
obviously you were still wear of that
game but but regardless of that I mean
where did you start to feel like you
know you might have a chance I mean this
a sixth ip7 idea was a bit surprising to
us what were your thoughts when he went
for it
well it's a very ambitious mob so he was
clearly playing for a win because if he
if he didn't want people that you just
played Bishop deterrence of eight six
and the position is very sterile but but
yeah a six be 697 is bare ambitious but
I think it's also a mistaken plan
because when I saw 94 few months ago
when I saw 94 thought what is risking
the position here his Knight is stuck on
b7 and I control the only open file in
the e-file this is safe to say well say
that one he went for a 697 you were
pretty happy because you're looking at
your teammates boards you know that a
Karan Nakamura was in the worst side of
a position you probably were happy that
he went for this to give you some
chances yeah sure I was I mean I
actually thought T throw might hold that
that pond on end game
it was very close I mean it was
difficult defending but I assumed he
would hold it because he always does but
it was a it was a big thing for Fabiano
to win so quickly with white against
very strong play well this game went on
as you said this a six ninety seventy it
kind of surprised us too we weren't as
bold as thinking it was but maybe bad
but then it then it turned around very
quickly is when you played this Bishop
takes b7 and then taking a6 move instead
of instead of just taking back on
obviously taking here would be bad but
wait when did you feel you were playing
for a win at what at one point just stop
me well no actually I was playing for a
win after he played 97 I think ok I
think that's a little better there
probably I could equalize with with
perfect play but I thought only blackest
chances because the night is just badly
plays on on b7 over like all n games
with the Queen trade is much better for
me because the knight is stuck there and
b7 making good come but but of course I
that probably white could hole with some
practical play and actually what he
played was pretty good I mean he had
very good holding chances yeah he he
also calculated well he saw this first
line here Ruby for Queens III take CP
Bishop basics and the funny part if this
all only worked for right because after
Queenie eight on the route c7 we need
eight
Bishop takes rook e1 Bishop f1 if we
need to here's check on C 890 he rook
takes and b7 they quintic b7 rook f1 and
it's a duro
and this actually maybe he s b eh7 yeah
and then may be obvious but anyway he's
not risking anything here okay so so
yeah I means I had to take with a takes
musics and I thought I'm not risking
anything here because my he's got some
pressure he's got some problems along
the back Frank right you know as you
probably wanted I don't know well as you
went for hearing we're just a couple
moves when you know with this Queen on
a4 and rook on d1 it's like you want to
play Queen a1 so badly but you don't
have space for your queen on the first
rank right so you know if they then even
though as b3 your queen has to retreat
so this rook h1 move when did you come
up with that and like in at first you
think that he was getting out or did you
always see this rook h1 which was such a
fantastic find
actually it's funny when I quit when I
played King g7 if you go back when I
played King g7 I thought the except King
g7 I thought when a one looks winning
for me so I don't know maybe this oh
maybe you're right
yeah I mean so I mean I was gonna play
King g7 and Queen e1 by could have
played Queen a1 right away and I'm play
I only realized that after because after
Queen a1 he has to move the bishop and
then I have Brooke h1 and so it's just
like totally lost already
yeah but I mean fortunately I want this
game otherwise I wouldn't be
to sleep may not think winning you
played the safe prophylactic move turned
out quitter what was winning right away
but that yeah yeah so now he prevented
it but but yeah I played Queen a to and
it's yeah it's probably very difficult
to defend here also I'm not sure if you
have any defense either because when a
tree threatens Queen d6 and Quincy one
yeah and the N my king is very safe
while his Bishop is not doing anything
cuz we were analyzing it we saw this we
highlighted that the king could run so
the obvious moves were good and there
were threats of Queen e6 but you you
answered all questions with the move
rook e1 which was just very nice for
vents Queen e6 and then and then the net
finally closes you get to bring the
knight in to h5 how does black finish
the job if the King sits here
yeah King eat your night I thought
Knight f4 yeah then I could even go to a
winning endgame I think yeah okay yeah
you can just take and take on g2 if you
audio yeah shouldn't be winning endgame
toka but yeah I think each tier was his
only move because king of Toulouse is
actually our thinking fed up King extra
maybe could go to h4 or something
Quincy one should be cleaning we'd like
to think writer or chess is cruel yeah
okay yeah I mean he offered the door
when he played win d3 and he was
probably close to equal at that point
but but but you don't like the draw yeah
yeah I thinking after was a muscle
blender here so he could have paid
something else
wow you go ahead go ahead you had a
question good well see you ultimately
secured the full point and so you move
on to the super file tomorrow to have a
rematch with China
so after this victory you're probably
feeling confident but what can you tell
everybody you know what will it be like
in a rematch will be a totally different
or do
expect the USA to come out on top once
more uh well first of all I'd like to
thank Illyria Sofia or for saving our
team yeah yeah I'd like to thank Kelly
refugia for saving our team and also for
beyond of course but he's our teammate
but yeah losing losing to Europe today
in in the morning was was a tough one
also because Europe was very lucky to
tie the match against India yesterday
so yeah I thought things were not going
well for us and and the thing that
players were we're down during the break
but we managed to manage to fight and
continue and yeah and survive and
tomorrow do we play one major two
matches
Danny's face is just like I don't know
because I've been so focused on this
event here and you know coming up and
your face I can't get over it guys I'm
as tired as you are I'm not playing but
we've been doing this since 4:00 a.m.
every day this week and I'm I don't know
the format I haven't even thinking about
tomorrow
so go ahead okay yeah well China's the
favorite because they have this they
have I got two hundred point rating
difference and under on the women board
yeah it is it is one match to see you
know Wesley I just wanted to see how to
facial gymnastics for a second well is
one match and they also have drawn since
Wesley before we let you go we have to
ask you the daily question because
behind what they have there I obsess
greatly they do have draw arts which is
which is crazy like I said I think if
they have draws they could give you guys
piece odds I don't know faith we might
do then they win automatically I guess
so I guess so
um yeah again yeah a lot of things huge
event I don't know if we're doing the
best we can here but let's get your let
your thoughts on the day the question I
think I think the first time we've ever
done a team event like this and trying
to come up with something exciting I
guess that's the the way the super final
will be played you're right but we asked
the fans what would it take to beat
China apparently it took Leslie so on
board three versus you young II so so uh
so that's the answer I guess to beat
China the super finals it's of Wesley so
of or three yeah now so we need the
quick win from Fabiana against Wang Hao
right okay well uh Leslie I mean I think
the the two-toed rods is kind of unfair
yeah it's gonna be tough way I really
got that back against the wall tomorrow
yeah well we wish you the best of luck
tomorrow
obviously and again huge huge
congratulations on on the day today
obviously kind of shock in the world
here with a dramatic finish but Wesley
been great to have you in these
interviews and good luck tomorrow
Thank You Danny I've always enjoyed
playing on your site and I always
enjoyed your dual commentary with Robert
and thank you to a perfect match
thank you much once the appreciate the
kind words and that's the skill tomorrow
a happy mother happy Mother's Day to
load us early so tomorrow all right
Wesley well we'll talk to you we'll talk
to you tomorrow
right right and here we have who they
will be facing team China as we said and
Wesley dropped out of the call there and
this will be the team we don't know the
exact roster will it be Howie fawn will
it be Joo and June on board for will
there be a different set up as far as
the boards one two and three right it's
some kind of crazy to predict I think
any any lineup they throw would be tough
to beat but but okay why don't we bring
up Team USA and and remind everybody
their roster who they'll be who they'll
be bringing
yep they have well as we know it car
Nakamura I'm bored one he did just
suffer his first loss of the match but
thankfully for the team it didn't matter
so he'll have to rebound but it's going
to be just 2-2 tie means that China wins
I know what I said though that doesn't
seem fair but then what's the point of
playing these first 10 rounds like if
China dominates the field
what if image should they have and I'm
not at all criticizing West it's his
opinion of course but I do believe that
the you know top team should get some
kind of advantage and Sports is often
home court home-field advantage so I
think that at the end of the day Chung
deserved their top place and you see
Team USA they're tough but if you look
at the overall top performers here Danny
Fabiano Caruana Yu yang he no surprise
that those two were the best two yep
we'll bring up our top performers slide
here as you were saying and Fabiano
Caruana you young ye obviously some
other players will not be competing
tomorrow unfortunately Artemyev and
firoozeh unfortunately for Team USA
won't be playing we're no kidding but it
was funny that Wesley said only reza got
the job done for them right crazy stuff
crazy stuff but it should be it should
be very exciting we know him Cara
Nakamura will be back on board one the
most likely looking looking for revenge
from today and he almost did hold that
end game it was interesting so can't
wait to see what happens team China
versus Team USA but tomorrow will be
Sunday happy early Mother's Day to those
who may not be able to join us tomorrow
if you have family plans to be with mom
we appreciate and support that but maybe
mom wants to watch some chess you know
we know Roberts mom does often and so
what I was doing I have no choice right
I'm covering the show with this but you
know then I can celebrate with my mom so
yeah I've got my kids planned we've got
a whole early morning plan cuz imma be
up at 4 a.m. and then got the oldest one
leading the way on some breakfast so I
can get out of here when the round is
done and head home so anyway it's gonna
be a lot of fun tomorrow we had the
super final in in the most dramatic
fashion possible if you missed at Team
USA defeats China here in round 10
leapfrogs Team Europe not even in terms
of match points as you can see but in
terms of total game points they barely
finish ahead
Robert the drama was real it was a ton
of fun and can't wait to see you
tomorrow so on behalf of the whole team
here everybody make sure you tune in
thanks for being with us shout out to
our our staff our production crew to
everyone all of our partners at feed a
help and make this have been possible
again it's been amazing and that we
can't wait for the last day of the feed
HS comm Online Nations Cup Sunday
tomorrow we'll see you then
[Music]